SIX PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES PACKER
BOARD JUST RADFORD CABALLERO
CORTESE DALLY DODD TORONTO.
EIGHT GLAZER GONZALEZ GROW
HERTZBERG WESTERN HER TADO JONES
KAMLAGER LAYERED LEYVA LIMON
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN
NIELSEN A CHOI BOGUE PAN
PORTANTINO ROCK. RUBIO SKINNER
STERN I'M BURKE BY CAL SKI
WIENER WILK. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR
GAS BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RIGHTS WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER TODAY BY SENATOR
RUBIO AFTER WHICH WE'RE GONNA
SHOULD REMAIN STANDING IN WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT. HELLO DAITO SEE
POPE FRANCIS SAID THE EARTH
HERSELF BURDENED AND LAID WASTE
IS AMONG THE MOST ABANDONED AND
MALTREATED UP ARE POOR WE HAVE
FORGOTTEN THAT WE OURSELVES ARE
DUST OF THE EARTH COMPASSIONATE
AND LOVING GOD YOU CREATED THE
WORLD FOR ALL OF US TO SHARE A
WORLD TO BEAUTY AND PLENTY
CREATE IN US A DESIRE TO LIVE
SIMPLY SO THEIR LIVES MAY
REFLECT YOUR GENEROSITY CREATOR
GOD. YOU HAVE US AND GAVE US
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE EARTH A
WORLD OF RICHET AND DELIGHT
CREATE IN US A DESIRE TO LIVE
SUSTAINABLY SO THAT THOSE WHO
FOLLOW AFTER US MAY ENJOY THE
FRUITS OF YOUR CREATION GOD OF
JUSTICE AND PEACE YOU GIVE US
THE CAPACITY TO CHANGE TO BRING
ABOUT A WORLD THAT MIRRORS YOUR
WISDOM CREATE IN US A DESIRE TO
ACT IN SOLIDARITY WITH ALL
CREATION SO THAT THE PILLARS OF
INJUSTICE CRUMBLE AND FALL LIFE
IS SET FREE TO FLOURISH WE ASK.
THIS IN YOUR NAME AMEN. BUDGET
TO THE FLAG OF UNITED. WHAT.
OUR MEMBERS WE MOVING TO
PRIVILEGES FOR DINNER WHY
BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE PURPOSE I'M
RECOGNITION OF SOME MEMBERS IN
THE GALLERY AND A CERTIFICATION
THE REDHEAD SITTIN. AND
COLLEAGUES ON THE EVE OF EARTH
DAY I THOUGHT IT APPROPRIATE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SOLAR COOKERS
INTERNATIONAL NOT A SOLAR
COOKERS INTERNATIONAL IS A
COMPANY HEADQUARTERED RIGHT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO THAT'S BEEN
ADVOCATING SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN. ROOF HUMAN IN
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. FOR
SUPPORTING CARBON FREE SOLAR
COOKERS TECHNOLOGIES IN REGIONS
OF THE WORLD THAT HAVE THE
GREATEST NEED SOME OF US THAT
ATTENDED THE COP AND GLASCO- HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN A PRESS CONFERENCE IN
RECOGNIZE- THE FOLKS THESE
REGIONS IN THE WORLD HAVE. ABOUT
THREE BILLION PEOPLE LIVING
THERE MOSTLY WOMEN. WHO COOK IN
AN OPEN FIRE USING WOULD WERE
YOU SEEING- I DONG AS THEIR FUEL
AND THAT LEADS TO D. FORCES
STATIONED THESE. DESERT VACATION
IN THE DEPLETION OF NUTRIENTS IN
THE SOIL IN ADDITION TO JUST
HUMAN HEALTH HAZARDS SO SOLAR
COOKERS INTERNATIONAL BURN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE KILLING OUR-
CURVE PRICE OF TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS BECAUSE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL. IN
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES AND
IMPROVING HEALTH TO WOMEN AND
FAMILIES AROUND THE WORLD SO
WHEN THE GALLERY TO OUR LEFT. WE
HAVE THE BOARD PRESIDENT DR-
SHE'S PAUL WROTE WHAT BORCHERT
TREASURER MICHAEL POPPER THE
PARIAN BOARD. MEMBER DR
JACQUELINE LUNDY AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR HI CAITLYN
HUGHES MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE- AROUND ONE OF A CLUSTER SO
WORKERS. WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. I ALSO
WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE FROM SPECIAL OLYMPIC
ATHLETES FROM BOTH NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS A STAFF
AND THEY'RE HERE VISITING A
COUPLE TODAY FOR SPECIAL
OLYMPICS DAY SO WELCOME TO OUR
SPECIAL OLYMPICS THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. ALL RIGHT MOVING ON
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS FROM COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MOTIONS AND RATHER
RESOLUTIONS. ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS WITH MICROPHONES UP.
SENATOR GROW. YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT- PLEASE REMOVE FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FOUR ESSERE
SIXTY NINE TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
DOES WILL NOTE. ANY OTHER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AT THE
STAR. HEARING THREE NINE MOVING
ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE WE HAVE SENATE SECOND
READING MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILLS NINE FIFTY
WITH AMENDMENTS. TWELVE FIFTY
SIX NINE THIRTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS NINE EIGHTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS TEN SEVENTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS TEN FIFTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS ELEVEN ELEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS ELEVEN FORTY TWO
WITH THE MAN I SENATE SURGERY
WILL BE DEEMED READ. NOW MOVING
ONTO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS WE
HAVE SENATOR LEHRER WE UP TO A
POINT- DO I AM TODAY I'M TWENTY
NINE AND THIRTY. EARLIER THANK
YOU ARE MISTER PRESIDENT FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE. IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF A LUXURY-
DAYLIGHT CREWS TO THE SEISMIC
SAFETY COMMISSION- SHE IS THE
DIRECTOR OF SONOMA COUNTY OFFICE
OF EQUITY SHE SERVES IN THE SLOT
ON THE COMMISSION DESIGNATED FOR
A MEMBER WITH A BACKGROUND IN
SOCIAL SERVICE. SHE WAS APPROVED
IN THE RULES COMMITTEE HEARING
ON APRIL SIX I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPHONE. CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- I LOVE
SITTING ON THE RULES COMMITTEE
WITH ALL THE THINGS THAT WE DO
ONE OF THE THINGS WE DO IS
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS AND I DO
BELIEVE WHOLEHEARTEDLY THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
ANYBODY HE WANTS FOR THE
APPOINTMENTS- USALLY WHEN I
OPPOSE AN APPOINTMENT I USUALLY
ASK THE QUESTIONS THAT I WANT TO
ASK. AND I'VE NEVER SPOKEN
ADAMANTLY AGAINST AN APPOINTMENT
LIKE I'M ABOUT READY TO DO TODAY
THIS INDIVIDUAL THAT HAS BEEN
APPOINTED TO THE SEISMIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE IS A SHEER. ACTIVIST
IN BY YOUR OWN ADMISSION SHE IS
AN ACTIVIST BY LITIGATION.
CALIFORNIA IS A HIGHLY MOST
HIGHEST LITIGATED STATE IN THE
NATION. AND TO HAVE SOMEONE LIKE
THIS IN ANY TYPE OF PUBLIC
OFFICE IS TRULY A DISGRACE THE
CALIFORNIA. I CAN TELL YOU THAT
WHILE SHE WAS AT THE LRB AND
DEALER BE HEADED NORTH THE IT IS
AN ORGANIZATION THAT STOOD
AGAINST FARMWORKERS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. FOR YEARS EVEN
AFTER THEY HAD VOTED SEVERAL
TIMES ARE HAD SIGNATURES
GATHERED SEVERAL TIMES FOR THEIR
VOTE TO BE COUNTED TO DECERTIFY
UFW. THE LRB CONTINUED ACTIVIST
ACTIVISION ACTIVISTS THROUGH
LITIGATION- AGAINST THESE
FARMWORKERS. RIGHT NOW I'M ON A
IN THE BAY AREA- OR THE NORTH
BAY AREA. THIS INDIVIDUAL IS
PART OF NORTH BAY JOBS FOR
JUSTICE WHERE THIS ORGANIZATION
PRETENDS TO PROTECT FARMWORKERS
THAT. OUR GREAT GROWERS-
REQUIRING THESE THESE GROWERS TO
BE ABLE TO PUT ALL OF THEIR
SAFETY DOCUMENTS INTO DIALECTS
THERE'S OVER THIRTY DIALECTS. IF
THIS INDIVIDUAL TOOK THREE
MINUTES OUT OF HER TWENTY FOUR
HOURS DAY POSITION AND SHE MET
WITH THESE FARMWORKERS IN THESE
GROWERS THEY WOULD TELL THEM
THEY WOULD TELL HER THAT. IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO THIS
TRANSLATION BECAUSE SOME OF
THESE DIALECTS OVER THIRTY OF
THEM SOME OF THEM ARE ONLY SPOKE
AND NOT WRITTEN. BUYER LIKE I
SAID HER OWN ADMISSION SHE'S AN
ACTIVIST THROUGH LITIGATION. AND
IT'S BE WHO'S ME AND I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THE GOVERNOR
WOULD APPOINT SOMEBODY USE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO PAY THEIR
SALARY- WHEN ESPECIALLY IN THE
NEW POSITION OF THE SEISMIC
SAFETY POSITION THAT SHE'S ABOUT
READY TO BE CONFIRMED FOR- WE
DON'T NEED ACTIVISTS THROUGH
LITIGATION IN SEISMIC SAFETY. WE
DON'T NEED OF LAWSUITS FILED
AGAINST HOSPITALS PRIVATE
BUSINESSES PRIVATE HOMES WE
DON'T NEED ANY OF THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE. WE NEED. OBVIOUSLY
BUILDING TO. I'M SAFE IN AND
WITHSTAND EARTHQUAKE BUT THIS
ACTIVISTS POSITION THAT'S BEING
FILLED TODAY IS COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE AND THIS PERSON
SHOULD NEVER HOLD A PLACE IN
PUBLIC OFFICE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
CINNABAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT. MEMBERS. I'D
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT MR THE CRUISE
. I WANT TO TALK ABOUT MR THE
CRUISE FROM SOMEONE WHO'S KNOWN
HER FOR LITERALLY YEARS. FIRST
AND FOREMOST I THINK WE NEED TO
CLARIFY TO THIS BODY. THAT THE
SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH LITIGATION.
NOTHING. MR THE CRUISE IS A
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT. HE IS
A PROVEN ATTORNEY HE'S A MOTHER
IN YES. SHE IS AN ADVOCATE FOR
FARMWORKERS. LET ME TELL YOU WHY
. SHE'S A DAUGHTER OF A FARM
WORKER FAMILY. WHO STRUGGLED WE
STRUGGLED GROWING UP HER PARENTS
WERE POOR THEY STRUGGLE TO BE
ABLE TO PAY THE RENT. KAMALA PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE. SO WHEN WE
ALL SEE STRUGGLE GROWING UP WE
WANT TO CHANGE THAT AS AN ADULT
. MR CRUZ IS NOT AN ACTIVIST. HE
SAID THE CHIEF FORMER CHIEF
DEPUTY COUNSEL IN THE CINEMA
COUNTY COUNTY COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
HE'S A SANTA ROSA CITY SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER RIGHT NOW. HE'S THE
FIRST DIRECTOR THE FIRST
DIRECTOR IN THE COUNTY SONORA TO
BE ABLE TO HEAD THE CINEMA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EQUITY ENSURING
THAT PEOPLE OF COLOR AND WOMEN
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE AND BY
THE WAY THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD ALL BE CHAMPION. SHE
BRINGS AMAZING EXPERIENCE TO BE
ABLE TO ESTABLISH EQUITY IN OUR
GOVERNMENT HE'S BEN TESTED WITH
GASTRIC DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
AND RESPONSE AND RECOVERY WHEN
SHE WAS A MEMBER OF THE COUNTY
COUNCIL TO REBUILD OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE DEVASTATED
BY THE TUBBS FIRE. I WANT TO SAY
ONE MORE TIME. THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLE ONE. SHE'S AN AMAZING
LEADER IN OUR COMMUNITY IN THIS
STATE WILL BE STRONGER WITH HER
SERVING ON THE COMMISSION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENT EARNS. CERVIX THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND I MUST
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE ON WHETHER
THIS DALY CRUISES AND ACTIVISTS
TO USE THE HER POSITION ON THE
SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION- I
ASKED HER WHY SHE WOULD WANT TO
SEND A BROCHURE TO EVERY RANCHER
IN THE STATE AND ASKING THEM. TO
GIVING THEM THE DIRECTION OF HOW
THEY MIGHT- WEIGH IN ON WHETHER
THEY HAVE ANY OF. VIOLATIONS
BUILDING INSPECTION PROBLEMS IN
THEIR OF RENTAL AND I ASKED HER
WHY WOULD SHE WANT TO SEND THAT
TO A CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICER SO
HE MIGHT IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
RELATE TO. OF THE RESIDENCE AND
CERTAINLY THE BUSINESS OWNERS
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO DO
CERTAIN KIND OF INSPECTIONS AND
SHE THOUGHT IT WAS MORE
APPROPRIATE AND MORE IMPACTFUL.
ARE THAT IT WENT DIRECTLY TO
INDIVIDUALS INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
NO KNOWLEDGE OF WHETHER THERE IS
A VIOLATION- IN THEIR BUILDING-
WITH CODE ENFORCEMENT
REGULATIONS AND THAT SEEMS TO ME
TO BE QUITE WIDE SWEEPING IN
TERMS OF ACTIVISM ACTIVIST.
ACTIVIST OUT- OPPORTUNITIES TO
GET THE RESIDENTS IN OF VARIOUS-
RENTAL SITUATIONS ARE CONCERNED
IN WORKSHOPS AND SH. WE HAVE A
VERY GOOD EXPLANATION TO THAT SO
I'M SORRY I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT HER EITHER BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE THAT SHE SEES HER NEW
POSITION AS WELL AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THE VERY THING BECAUSE-
OF. A LEGAL ACTIONS IN AREAS
WHERE PEOPLE WILL HAVE TO DEFEND
THAT OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL
BE UNDER OUR THAT KIND OF
SURVEILLANCE AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S REALLY IN OVERREACH IN
TERMS OF THE RESPONSIBILITIES
AND AUTHORITIES THAT ARE GIVEN
TO PEOPLE WHO SERVE ON THIS
BOARD. SO I ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK
YOU. ANY FOR THE- DEBATE ON UP
ON. IN NINETEEN NINE EARLIER
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER PER OF
WE RAN TO GROUND TO MAKE. HE
THAT A BOARD MEMBER DOES NOT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO INSTITUTE
LITIGATION BY THEMSELVES I WILL
TAKE SENATOR MCGUIRE'S COMMENTS
AS A CLOSE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SIGNATURE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE POINT.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES NO BAKER. I FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD I HAVE ITEM AYE FOR
TESTING I DALY NO DODD. HI
YOU'RE AWESOME I EGGMAN I BLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
I WAS SEVEN. HYPER TADA I JONES
NO KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA
AYE THE MOST. I MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ NO MAN I NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN NO A CHOI BOGUE NO PAN
HI PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
. I SKINNER I STERN AYE NUMBER
FIVE BY CASTING. I WIENER AYE
WILK. HIGHS THIRTY ONE KNOWS
EIGHT THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NOW MOVING ON THE FILE
ITEM THIRTY THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM THIRTY AS
THE CONFIRMATION OF ISAC FOR
YOUR GUESTS THOROTON TOUCH KEY
AND BUFFY MCQUILLAN TO THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION ALL THREE APPOINTEES
WERE UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL SIXTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THESE APPOINTMENTS
. HEARING TO NINE THIRTY- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES I
BAKER HI FORTUS I BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO. I FOR TESTING I DALY
AYE DODD. FIVE ZERO SEVEN FIVE
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I
WROTE HI HERTZBERG HI WESTERN I
HER TADO. I JONES. I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED AYE LEYVA I LIMÓN AYE
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ AYE MIN I
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN AYE A CELLO
BOW I CAN. I PORTANTINO. HI ROTH
AYE RUBIO I SKINNER. HI STERN
AYE NUMBER I Y. CASKEY AYE
WIENER AYE WILK. HIGHS THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENTS
ARE CONFIRMED NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ONTO UNFINISHED BUSINESS
ITEM THIRTY ONE. SAN RAMON.
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR. AN ACT RELATING TO
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE A
SECRET TO ME DEALING CENTER LIMO
. THANK YOU SB FIVE SEVEN SEVEN
IS BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES I
INTRODUCED THIS BILL LAST YEAR
TO ADDRESS THE SUNSET PROVISION
IN OUR LENDING LAWS THAT ALLOW
COMPANIES WHO MAKE ONLY ONE
COMMERCIAL LOAN IN A TWELVE
MONTH PERIOD TO BE EXEMPT FROM
OUR LICENSING REQUIREMENTS. THIS
EXEMPTION IS USED PRIMARILY FOR
FINANCING PROJECTS RELATED TO
NEW MARKET TAX CREDITS WHICH
AIMS TO ATTRACT PRIVATE CAPITAL
INTO LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL WAS HELD
UP BY THE TWELVE BILL LIMIT
ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC IN THE PROVISION WITH
THE EXEMPTION SUNSET ON JANUARY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR. WE ADDED AN
URGENCY CLAUSE TO THE BILL IN
JANUARY TO ADD THE EXEMPTION
BACK INTO THE STATUE AND THIS
BILL IS NOW BACK FROM THE
ASSEMBLY TO CONCUR THOSE
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR. I ABOUT. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. EIGHTY
NINE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
USING NANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING TO NINE HOURS
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO ON THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
CONFIRMED CONFIRMED IT. NOW
MOVING ON TO SENATE THIRD
READING. WE HAVE SIX ITEMS SEVEN
ITEMS AND FIRST UP IS I'M FORTY
ONE. SKINNER GARNERED- PRAYER
CHEERS. I MET MA'AM CENTER
PLEASE READ. SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION TWELVE BY SENATOR
SKINNER RELATIVE TO THE EQUAL
RIGHTS AMENDMENT CENTERS GONNA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS I STAND BEFORE YOU
AS THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR S. G.
R. J. R. TWELVE. FIFTY YEARS AGO
CONGRESS APPROVED THE EQUAL
RIGHTS AMENDMENT AND BEGAN THE
ERA'S JOURNEY FOR STATE BY STATE
RATIFICATION. UNDER OUR
CONSTITUTION RICK WE REQUIRE
THIRTY EIGHT STATES TO RATIFY
FOR AMENDMENTS TO BECOME A PART
OF THE CONSTITUTION. WE NOW HAVE
THIRTY EIGHT STATES WHO HAVE
RATIFIED THE ERA AS THE TWENTY
EIGHTH AMENDMENT. IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS ILLINOIS NEVADA AND
MOST RECENTLY VIRGINIA. BECAME
IN VIRGINIA IN TWENTY TWENTY
BECAME THE THIRTY EIGHTH AND
FINAL STATE ACHIEVING THAT
NECESSARY RATIFICATION YES THE
FEDERAL ARCHIVIST HAS NOT
CERTIFIED RATIFICATION OR
PUBLISHED ERA CITING THE
ARBITRARY DEADLINE THAT CONGRESS
SETS IN. ONE OF ITS BILLS FOR
WHEN RATIFICATION NEEDED TO BE
DONE NOW IF YOU LOOK AT THE
HISTORY OF OUR CONSTITUTION
THERE ARE MANY AMENDMENTS THAT
TOOK YEARS FOR PASSAGE AND MANY
AMENDMENTS THAT HAD NO DEADLINES
AND THERE'S NOTHING IN OUR
CONSTITUTION THAT STATES EIGHT
EIGHT AN AMENDMENT MUST HAVE
MUST BE APPROVED WITHIN A
CERTAIN TIME PERIOD. AND THE ERA
IS NOT THE ONLY AMENDMENT THAT
IS NEEDED MANY YEARS FOR
RATIFICATION THERE IS ONE THAT
IS NOW IN THE CONSTITUTION THAT
TOOK TWO HUNDRED YEARS BEFORE IT
HAD THE NECESSARY STATES. THE
EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT LANGUAGE
IS VERY SIMPLE. IT BASICALLY
STATES THAT THERE WILL THAT
THERE WILL BE NO. LEGAL
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON SEX
WHICH ADVANCES JUSTICE FOR WOMEN
AND GIRLS AND GENDER EXPANSIVE
INDIVIDUALS. AND WITH THE AREAS
PART OF OUR CONSTITUTION IT WILL
ALLOW LAWS THAT PERPETUATE
INEQUALITY OR IN EQUITABLE
GENDER ROLES TO BE STRUCK DOWN
AS UNCONSTITUTIONAL. S. T. A. R.
TWELVE URGES CONGRESS TO PASS H.
R. EIGHT NINETY ONE AUTHORED BY
CALIFORNIA'S OWN CONGRESSWOMAN
JACKIE SPEER DECLARING THAT THE
ERA HAS MET ITS REQUIREMENTS TO
BECOME THE TWENTY EIGHTH
AMENDMENT. AND IT CALLS ON THE
ARCHIVISTS TO CERTIFY AND PUBLIC
PUBLISHED THE RATIFICATION OF
THE ERA. THIS IS. XIN ON SEX
DISCRIMINATION AND
DISCRIMINATION BASED SOME SIMPLY
AND SOLELY ON. ONE'S GENDER AND
WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
RATE SOONER RATHER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AS CHAIR OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS IT IS MY HONOR TO RISE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AS J.
R. TWELVE. CALLING ON CONGRESS
TO PASS HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHT
NINETY ONE AND FINALLY
FORMALIZED THE APPROVAL OF THE
EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT IT IS SO
LONG PAST TIME THAT OUR NATION
ADOPT THIS FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT
INTO OUR CONSTITUTION. THE
TWENTY EIGHTH AMENDMENT TO THE
SACRED DOCUMENT FIRST RATIFIED
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT YES
CALIFORNIANS SOME OTHER STATES
HAVE ENSHRINED NON
DISCRIMINATION AND EQUAL
PROTECTION PROVISIONS INTO OUR
CONSTITUTION AND STATE LAWS
THERE STILL REMAINS A
FUNDAMENTAL NEED TO FINALIZE
THIS AMENDMENT INTO THE UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION. LIKE OTHER
QUOTE UNQUOTE FEDERAL RIGHTS
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS FOR WOMEN AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION. THEY ARE AT BEST
IN LEGAL LIMBO AND SUBJECT TO
CHANGE DUE TO NEW
INTERPRETATIONS OF LEGAL
PRECEDENT WOMEN OF COLOR ARE IS.
IN JEOPARDY FONG CHRISTMAS
THEREFORE MOVES FAST TO APPROVE
THIS RESOLUTION AND FORMALIZE
THE RATIFICATION OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTH AMENDMENT TO THE UNITED
STATES BECAUSE- TO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR YEARS IS LONG
ENOUGH. FOR THE WOMEN AND THE
GIRLS OF OUR COUNTRY TO RECEIVE
A FORMAL ASSURANCE BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT THE
QUOTE EQUALITY OF RIGHTS UNDER
THE LAW SHALL NOT BE DENIED OR
ABRIDGED. BY THE UNITED STATES
OR BY ANY STATE ON ACCOUNT OF
SEX END QUOTE I THANK THE
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION UP FOR A VOTE AND I
URGE ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES. TO
JOIN US IN AN ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT OF S. J. R. TWELVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR DORADO
SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS- I TO- RICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. C. R.
TWELVE ON BEHALF OF THIS CHAIR
OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN SIKANDAR
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. WHICH THIS
RESOLUTION WHICH URGES CONGRESS
TO RATIFY THE EQUAL RIGHTS TO
MEN THAT ACT AS A TWENTY EIGHTH
AMENDMENT TO THE CONSTITUTION.
THIS ACT IS ESSENTIAL TO
GUARANTEE EQUAL RIGHTS
REGARDLESS OF ONE SEX AND
FORTUNE WE HAVE SEEN IN THE API
COMMUNITY THAT- WOMEN HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY TARGETED WITH. HATE
ACCORDING TO STOP AB I HATE MORE
THAN HALF OF THE HEAT INCIDENTS
REPORTED SINCE THE START
PANDEMIC HAVE BEEN REPORTED BY
WOMEN. AND EARLIER THIS YEAR IS
THE ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF THE
SHOOTING ATLANTA WHERE API WOMEN
WERE TARGETED AND KILLED.
UNFORTUNATELY WOMEN ARE STILL
NOT SEEN AS EQUALS AND PART OF
THAT CULTURE STEM FROM ADEQUATE
POLICIES THAT PREVIOUSLY
ENCOURAGED IT. AND WE STILL OF
COURSE HAVE MORE WORK TO DO.
VEHICLE RIGHTS ACT TAKES ACTIONS
TO RATIFY AND GUARANTEE IN THE
CONSTITUTION. THAT ALL. ERIC IN
SPARTA. EACH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
ME I'VE ON YOUR TO THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR PAM CENTER
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND THAT'S YOUR
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I STAND
IN SUPPORT OF SJR TWELVE WHICH
pTHE TWENTY EIGHTH AMENDMENT OF
OUR CONSTITUTION. AS J. R.
TWELVE ALSO CALLED ON THE US
CONGRESS TO APPROVE HOUSE
RESOLUTION EIGHT NINETY ONE
AUTHORED BY OUR FORMER MEMBER
AND CALIFORNIA'S OWN
CONGRESSWOMAN JACKIE SPEER.
WOMEN HAVE BEEN GREAT SOURCES OF
INSPIRATION AND LEADERSHIP FOR
MANY GENERATIONS SINCE. THE
ORIGIN OF THIS COUNTRY IS OFTEN
STATED IF YOU WANT SOMETHING
SAID YOU ASKED THE MAN IF YOU
WANT SOMETHING DONE YOU ASKED A
WOMAN. IS ALSO SAID IT'S A MAN'S
WORLD BUT WE ALL KNOW A WOMAN
MEXICO AROUND WOMEN FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS HAVE ONE IMPORTANT
ADVANCEMENTS IN THE MOVEMENT
THEY'VE HELP SHAPE POLICIES AND
SOCIETY AND CULTURE THAT. MORE
THAT MOVE OUR STATE BUDGET TODAY
AND OUR COUNTRY IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION DESPITE ALL OF THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS MILESTONES IN
HISTORICAL POSITIONS WOMEN. HAVE
HELD. THERE ARE STILL NOT
LEGALLY PROTECTED AGAINST GENDER
AND SEX DISCRIMINATION IN UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION. THE EQUAL
RIGHTS AMENDMENT WHICH PROVIDES
AN IS EXPLICIT CONSTITUTIONAL
GUARANTEE OF SEX EQUALITY IS
CRITICAL. TO FILLING THE
FUNDAMENTAL ASPECTS EXCLUDED
FROM THE CONSTITUTION. IN
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE ONE YEAR
AFTER THE PASSAGE OF THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT. WOMEN'S
RIGHT LEADERS PROPOSED THE FIRST
EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT AFTER THE
DEMANDS FOR GENDER. REQUIRE
EQUALITY RESURFACED B. R. A. WAS
SUBSEQUENTLY INTRODUCED IN
CONGRESS FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE AND PASS
CONGRESS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO. THIRTY FIVE OF THIRTY EIGHT
STATES QUICKLY RATIFIED THE
AMENDMENT NEEDED FOR IT TO
BECOME PART OF THE CONSTITUTION
HOWEVER ON JANUARY. TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO VIRGINIA HAS
AS A FINAL STATE TO RATIFY THE
CEMENT WHAT'S THE FINAL STATE I
SHOULD SAY WOMEN AVE AND
CONTINUE TO BE A PIVOTAL PART OF
OUR SOCIETY WE SHOULD ENSURE
THAT ONE OF THE MOST DEVELOPED
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD. THAT
THEY HAVE EQUAL CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTION FROM GENDER AND SEX
DISCRIMINATION WOMEN FACE
DISCRIMINATION OF UNEQUAL PAY
WORKPLACE HARASSMENT PREGNANCY
PREGNANCY DISCRIMINATION AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ARE HIGHER
RATE THAN MEN. PARTICULARLY
THOSE WHO ARE FROM HISTORICALLY
MORE MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES AS
WE LOOK TO RECOVERY. EQUITABLY
AS A STATE IN THE NATION WE MUST
DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO PROTECT
ALL AMERICANS FROM
DISCRIMINATION THE EQUAL RIGHTS
AMENDMENT PROVIDES A STRONGER
CONSTITUTIONAL BASIS FOR
COMBATING SEX DISCRIMINATION AND
ALLOWS CONGRESS MORE THORNY TO
ENACT WALLS. THAT INSURERS SEX
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA HAVING LONG
BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT WHEN IT
COMES TO WOMEN'S RIGHTS AND THAT
TRADITION REMAINS TODAY. I MADE
NOTE OF SENATORS BEER AUTHORING
THIS HOUSE RESOLUTION SENATOR
DIANNE FEINSTEIN AS WELL AS
SENATOR ALEX PADILLA HAVE JOINED
IN THE EFFORTS ADVOCATE FOR THE
SAME RESOLUTION IN THE SENATE AS
WELL. MEMBERS LET US FOLLOW THE
EXAMPLE OF SENATOR SKINNER AND
OUR FELLOW COLLEAGUES ON THE
HILL IN SUPPORT SJR TWELVE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR BRADFORD SENATOR
WIENER. THANK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
OUT OF. THANK YOU MATT THE ONE.
THEY'RE TRYING TO A VERY OWN
SENTIMENT MESSAGE I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT ARISES BY
SYRACUSE CAUCUS- IN- SUPPORT OF
STR TWELVE AND ASKED- MEMBERS TO
VOTE FOR IT- ARE CAUCUS AND
JEWISH COMMUNITY HAS BEEN A
STRONG LONG SUPPORTER OF GENDER
EQUITY AND WITH A LONG HISTORY
OF AMAZING- JEWISH WOMEN WHO
HELPED LEAD OUR COUNTRY- WHETHER
REPAIR TENS OF BURGER BELLA
ABZUG- AND SO FORTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE HEARING
SEEN ON CENTERS GOING TO TALK TO
CLOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS BY MY
COLLEAGUES ALL EXTREMELY- SPOT
ON AND WHY WE NEED THIS
AMENDMENT FIFTY YEARS AGO AT THE
POINT THAT CONGRESS WAS SETTING
OFF THE ERA'S JOURNEY I WAS
ELECTED THE FIRST GIRL PRESIDENT
OF MY HIGH SCHOOL. AND OF COURSE
I WAS VERY NAIVE I THOUGHT AFTER
THAT POINT THAT HEY THERE
WOULDN'T BE ARDLEY ANYTHING LEFT
WITHIN A FEW YEARS THAT NEEDED
TO HAVE YOU KNOW WOMEN BE FIRST
IN OTHER WORDS THAT UP WITHIN A
FEW YEARS WOMEN IN THE SUPREME
COURT WOMEN AS PRESIDENT WOMEN
AS GOVERNOR'S WOMEN AS CEOS YOU
NAME IT. WELL LIKE I SAID I WAS
NAIVE FIFTY YEARS LATER WE ARE
STILL IN A SITUATION WHERE THERE
ARE VERY FEW WOMEN CEOS VERY FEW
WOMEN ON CORPORATE BOARDS THE
THANK GOODNESS THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HELP THAT IN
CALIFORNIA FIVE NO WOMAN
GOVERNOR YET NO IN CALIFORNIA NO
WOMAN PRESIDENT THERE'S A GLASS
CEILING THERE IS UNEQUAL PAY
AND- GENDER BIAS IS STILL
CORRECT INTO OUR LAWS OR
PRACTICES OUR SOCIETAL CULTURE
AND IT'S TIME FOR THAT TO END
NOW WILL HAVING THE E. R. A. B.
THE TWENTY EIGHTH AMENDMENT AND
THAT IS. BY NO MEANS BUT IT AT
LEAST INSURERS THAT GENDER
CANNOT BE THE BASIS THAT
DISCRIMINATION IN ANY LAW OR ANY
PRACTICE AND IF THAT OCCURS THEN
BY THAT CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
THOSE LAWS CAN BE STRUCK DOWN
THOSE PRACTICES CAN BE STRUCK
DOWN AND THIS IS WHY WE NEED THE
ERA MORE THAN EVER TODAY AND
WITHOUT AYE AYE. VOTE ON SJR
TWELVE. THANK YOU SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM FORTY
ONE. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BAKER HI
FORTUS BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO
AYE PROTESTING AYE DOLLY. DODD I
DURACELL I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG AYE
HUESO I FURTADO I JONES.
KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LEYVA AYE
LIMON I MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ.
MAN I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. A CHOI
BOGUE PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN
HI I'M BURKE HI WHAT KASKY HI
WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES PORGES
DALAI. GROVE JONES. MELENDEZ
NIELSEN OTOBO WELL. HIGHS THIRTY
ONE KNOWS IT ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY. INTERLAYER HE'S
PREPARED SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL NINE SIXTY NINE BY
SENATOR LAYERED AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC HEALTH. CENTER LURK
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT IN THE
FIRST BILL THAT WE ADOPTED THIS
YEAR WAS TO AN URGENCY MEASURE
TO CREATE A WATSONVILLE HOSPITAL
DISTRICT IN MOVING THAT BILL
FROM START TO FINISH IN UNDER
THREE WEEKS HI COMMITTED TO DO
SOME REPORTS. ARE IN A BILL AS A
FOLLOW UP BILL THIS BILL IS THAT
BILL IT ACCOMPLISHES IT THEIR
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
INNOVATE HEARING SEEN NONE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
KNOW WHAT THIS IS ALL DOUBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USE IN A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. NINETY NINE OZ THREE
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE
SENATOR ALERT AGAIN SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. SENATE BILL EIGHT
SIXTY SEVEN BY SENATOR LAYERED
AN ACT RELATING TO SEA LEVEL
RISE SOONER OR LATER. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT IN THE PREVIOUS
BILL I TOLD YOU THAT I HAD TO
MOVE A BILL TO SAVE THE
WATSONVILLE HOSPITAL IN UNDER
THREE WEEKS THAT BILL WAS A SEA
LEVEL RISE BILL THAT WAS ON THE
FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY. HIRED
REPRODUCE THE SAME BILL SINCE I
BECAME THE HOSPITAL BILL- IT
UPDATES TO SEA LEVEL- SEA LEVEL
RISE DATABASE IT THERE WAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT GOING OUT
THERE SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES I
ASKED FOR YOUR I. PHONE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSS AND DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE HEARING INTO NONE THIS
TOO IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. EMERGENCY NINE OZ THIRTY
NINE. KNOWS IT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR SENATOR
PORTANTINO. AS YOU PREPARE D. AS
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL NINE FORTY ONE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AN ACT RELATING TO
PEOPLE INSTRUCTION. CENTER
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SB NINE FORTY ONE WHICH
IS A BILL TO STREAMLINE
COOPERATION AMONG SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. CERTAINLY THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE CALIFORNIA FACE WAS
EVIDENT BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
OBVIOUSLY THE PANDEMIC
EXACERBATED- THOSE ISSUES- MANY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. LOST BOTH DUAL
LANGUAGE IMMERSION TEACHERS AND
CERTAINLY STRUGGLE TO FIND
ADEQUATE NUMBER OF STEM
TEACHERS- RATHER THAN RELYING ON
EMERGENCY CREDENTIALS ARE
CANCELING CLASSES THIS BILL
ALLOWS SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
COOPERATE SO IF ONE SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS AN OPENING IN A
CALCULUS CLASS IN ANOTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS STUDENTS IN NEED OF
CALCULUS. THEY CAN COOPERATE AND
SHARE THE RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE STUDENTS DON'T LOSE
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES IN
PARTICULAR DUAL LANGUAGE CLASSES
STRUGGLED TO FIND ENOUGH
TEACHERS- BILINGUAL TEACHERS
FOR- THOSE CLASSES AND SO AGAIN
IF A TEACHER HAS A SPANISH
SPEAKING MATH TEACHER AND
ANOTHER SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
STUDENTS THAT NEED A SPANISH
SPEAKING MATH TEACHER. THEY CAN
WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITHOUT
HAVING TO GO THROUGH A
BUREAUCRACY TO MAKE THOSE
COOPERATION TAPPAN. THIS BILL
DOES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE HEARING SEEN ON THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. ON FILE ITEM FIFTY
FOUR. HEARING TÍNH NINE. THIRTY
NINE KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN
SENATOR CORTESE PREPARED HE IS
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE SENATE
BILL TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR CORTEZ SEE AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT CENTER
CORTEZ. MISTER PRESIDENT TO
THANK YOUR RICE RESENT SB TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO COMPLETE
AND PUBLISH AN ANNUAL REPORT
CONTINUES TO TWO STICKS ON STATE
WORK INJURIES OCCUPATIONAL
DISEASES AND FATALITIES BY
INDUSTRY CLASSIFICATIONS. BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST EACH YEAR
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT TO SUBMIT THE
ANNUAL REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING TO A NON MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE
ITEM FIFTY SEVEN. HEARING C.
NINE FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING ON
THE FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE SENATOR
GONZALEZ. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
. SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
RELATIVE TO WOMEN AND GIRLS IN
STEM WEEK. SENATOR GONZALEZ
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT STR
NINETY WHICH WILL DECLARE THE
WEEK OF APRIL THIRD THROUGH THE
NINTH AS WOMEN AND GIRLS IN STEM
WEEK WOMEN ARE A LARGE PART AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF THE ECONOMIC
ENGINE THAT POWERS OUR STATE AND
YET CONTINUE TO MAKE UP ONLY A
MINORITY OF OUR STEM WORKFORCE.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WOMEN
RECEIVE. UNDERGRADUATE DEGREES
THE ONLY ACCOUNT 424% OF STEM
JOBS. THESE NUMBERS ARE EVEN
LOWER FOR WOMEN OF COLOR.
INCLUDING WOMEN AND THE UNIQUE
VIEWS AND EXPERIENCES THEY
POSSESSES. VITAL PART OF
ENHANCING CALIFORNIA'S STEM
WORKFORCE IN INDUSTRIES. AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW PRIOR TO MY ELECTION
IN THE STATE SENATE I WORK FOR
MICROSOFT AND SAW FIRSTHAND. HOW
FEW WOMEN ARE WORKING IN STEM
AND THAT'S WHY MY EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THAT UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY YOUNG
GIRLS OF COLOR. MADE IN STEM
CAREERS. WOMEN AND GIRLS IN STEM
WEEK REMIND US THAT CALIFORNIA
MUST CONTINUE TO INVEST IN OUR
YOUNG WOMEN. AND PROVIDE AVENUES
FOR THEM TO EXPLORE
OPPORTUNITIES AND ALL OF THESE
AREAS THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. ON STR. STR
NINETY. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
MEANT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I
RISE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. MY
MOTHER WAS A CHEMISTRY PHD WENT
ON TO WORK IN THE SEMICONDUCTOR
INDUSTRY. AND I REMEMBER HER
COMING HOME AT TIMES- IN TEARS
BECAUSE SHE WAS. A SUBJECT OF SO
MUCH DISCRIMINATION AS THE ONLY
WOMAN TYPICALLY THE ONLY WOMAN
OF COLOR A PERSON OF COLOR. MANY
THE ROOM SHE SAID SHE SHE
DEFINITELY HIT A GLASS CEILING.
A BAMBOO CEILING I HAVE A NINE
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER RIGHT NOW
WHO'S VERY GOOD AT MATH AND
SCIENCE AND I'LL MAKE SURE SHE
DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME BARRIERS
TO SUCCESS THAT MY MOTHER DID SO
I WOULD ASK TO BE CO AUTHORED
THE PREPARATORY I'M AND- URGE
YOU TO. SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
INNOVATE. CENTER PAM. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT- CENTERS I TO RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SCR NINETY
ALTHOUGH I THINK YOU SHOULD BE
STEP. GIRLS IN STEM YEAR EVERY
YEAR- AND THE ONE THING MY GOOD
FRIENDS LONG BEACH FOR BRING
THIS FOR TO SOMEONE WHO
PERSONALLY PURSUED A STEM
CAREER. AND THAT UNFORTUNATELY
TO ALL WOMEN AND GIRLS ARE
GIRLS- AND- THAT TENSION ONE.
ARE ACTUALLY EVEN DISCOURAGED
FROM PURSUING STEM- AND- THAT
CERTAINLY NEEDS TO CHANGE- IN
ADDITION- YOU KNOW MY MOTHER IS
ACTUALLY A- NOT DETECTION AND
PURSUED- COMPUTER. SCIENCE
HERSELF AND SO. IN MANY WAYS AND
AGAIN WHEN SHE WENT TO COLLEGE
SHE WAS ACTUALLY ONE OF A VERY
SMALL NUMBER OF GIRLS AND-
ENGINEERING COLLEGE. AND I
THINK- AND I APPRECIATE THAT MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM IRVINE THAT
SHARING THE STORY OF HIS FAMILY
AS WELL- THERE ARE A LOT. OF
GOING ALL THE WAY FOR. BEING
DISCOURAGED ME PURSUING A CAREER
BEING ADVISED AGAINST IT
UNFORTUNATELY A CULTURAL- PUSH
AGAINST THE- GIRL TO GO INTO
STEM- IT'S- ALL THE WAY TO WIN
THE ONES WHO ACTUALLY MAKE IT IN
THE STEM. AGAIN OFTENTIMES
HAVING- BARRIERS- PEOPLE A
DISCRIMINATION. AND- LOSS OF
OPPORTUNITY IN LOSS OF
MENTORSHIPS SO. IS SO VERY
IMPORTANT WE RECOGNIZE. HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO ENCOURAGE
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN STEM AND BE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE. THE KIND OF
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES THAT- OFTEN
ARE TAKEN. TO VERY MUCH BYE
GRANTED BY- THE OTHER UP FIVE
FIVE NINE SO AGAIN OF REALLY
WANT THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM A
LONG BEACH RINGS FORD AND- LET'S
SAY CONTINUE SEND THAT MESSAGE
THAT. WE NEED TO WOMEN IN STAFF-
WE NEED THAT TALENT AND- IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE-
RECOGNIZE THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR PAT ANY FOR THE-
SURVEYED. ON THE SITE. ANY
FURTHER THE- OR THE ON ITEM.
TURNING TO NINE. IS ANY
OBJECTION TO YOU IT ON ROLL CALL
ON SIDE OF. SONORA JACK'S I
THIRTY NINE. KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSED. NOW MEMBERS
REMOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN SOONER HERTZBERG
HE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL ELEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
AN ACT RELATING TO WATER. CENTER
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT SENATORS
. WE FIND OURSELVES EACH OF US
IN ALL THE COMMUNITIES
REPRESENTED ALL TOO FAMILIAR
CYCLE OF DROUGHT. NATURE'S
CHANGE FASTER THAN ANYONE
EXPECTED THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE
HAVE LESS WATER TO GO AROUND FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT OR THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY AND FOR
ALL OF OUR HOMES AND OUR
FAMILIES. EVERY DAY WE READ THE
NEWS THE HEADLINES ABOUT HOW THE
SEVERE HOW DO A SEVERE THE
DROUGHT GROSS. LA TIMES
HEADLINE. AS DROUGHT HAMMERS
MONA LAKE THIRSTY LOS ANGELES
MUST LOOK ELSEWHERE FOR WATER
HEADLINE. MERCURYNEWS SIERRA
SNOWPACK FAILS TO ONE OF FALLS
TO ONE OF THE LOWEST LEVELS IN
SEVENTY YEARS HEADLINE ABC SEVEN
NEWS DATA SHOWS DRIEST JANUARY
THROUGH MARCH IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY HEADLINE CNN LAKE POWELL
IS ABOUT TO DROP BELOW A
CRITICAL LEVEL. NEVER REACHED
BEFORE AS DROUGHT RAGES ON. AND
THE L. A. TIMES AGAIN WESTERN
MEGA DROUGHT IS THE WORST IN
TWELVE HUNDRED YEARS.
INTENSIFIED BY CLIMATE CHANGE
STUDY FINDS. THESE ARE JUST FEW
OF THE EXTRAORDINARY HEADLINES
AS WE FACE. OUR GOVERNOR
RECENTLY SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER IS ANOTHER STARK WARNING.
OF HOW STRESSED OUR WATER
SUPPLIES HAVE BECOME AND AT THE
WORST OF THE DROUGHT IS YES TO
COME. AFTER OUR LAST DROUGHT
THAT ENDED A MERE SIX YEARS AGO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN I
PASSED A PACKAGE OF BILLS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH GOVERNOR BROWN
CHANGING WATER CONSERVATION AS
WE KNOW IT. THIS PACKAGE WAS
RESULT OF A TWO YEAR EFFORT
AMONG US IN BOTH HOUSES IN WHICH
WE HELD HEARINGS AND SOLICIT
INPUT AND FEEDBACK FROM DOZENS
OF ORGANIZATIONS. AT THE OUTCOME
OF THESE NEGOTIATIONS WAS TO SET
THE EXCUSE ME THE OUTCOME IS
NEGOTIATIONS WAS TO SET
RESIDENTIAL IN THE RESIDENTIAL
USE STANDARDS. AND WE ASKED THE
WATER RESOURCES AND STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TAKE A
LOOK AT THOSE STANDARDS AND THE
CURRENT USAGE AND COME BACK TO
US WITH RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
UPDATING THOSE STANDARDS. AS
THAT MEASURES AND THAT MEASURE
IS WHAT IS BEFORE US HERE TODAY
ON THIS FLOOR. WE'RE UPDATING
THE STANDARDS BASED UPON THE
BEST AVAILABLE DATA CURRENT
USAGE AND BEST PRACTICES.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS BEEN
MEMBERS ON THE FOREFRONT OF
EFFICIENCY. BUT WE ALWAYS TOLD
THAT IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO ACHIEVE
UNTIL WE ACTUALLY DO IT. JUST
LOOK AT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND HOW WE SET STANDARDS
TAILPIPE EMISSIONS I'LL NEVER
FORGET WHEN SOMEONE CENTER
PAVLEY THEN ASSEMBLY MILLIMAN
PAVLEY TALK ABOUT TAILPIPE
EMISSIONS IMPOSSIBLE WHEN
GOVERNOR BROWN IN THE FIRST TERM
TALKED ABOUT. THE END OF. AND
WE'RE GONNA SETS ARE USUALLY
TROUBLE IMPOSSIBLE NOW THE WHOLE
COUNTRY REALIZING THAT THE R. P.
S. STANDARD IMPOSSIBLE NOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND EVEN UNDER
PRESIDENT NIXON UNDER THE CLEAN
AIR ACT IMPOSSIBLE WHEN I WAS
GROWING UP IN LOS ANGELES AND WE
HAD TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
DAYS. OF SMOG THAT ALERTS AND
NOW THERE'S BEEN NONE.
IMPOSSIBLE WE HAVE TO ENGAGE.
NOW THERE'S SOME ARGUMENTS THAT
SAY THAT YOU CAN ONLY FLUSH THE
TOILET ONCE TODAY UNDER THESE
STANDARDS. ARE AND TAKE A SHOWER
EVERY OTHER DAY BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT IS NOT
FACTUAL IT IS GREAT FODDER FOR
TWITTER IN THIS SOCIAL MEDIA
WAR. UNFORTUNATELY IT'S NOT THE
TRUTH. WE BUILT IN FLEXIBILITY
IN THE ORIGINAL PACKAGE THE
INDOOR EFFICIENCY STANDARDS THE
SUBJECT OF THIS MEASURE. ARE
JUST ONE PART OF A TOTAL FORMULA
TO DETERMINE HOW WATER USAGE
MUST BE MADE. BETTER OVERALL
WATER JUICE OF THE ISSUE ON A
SYSTEM WIDE BASIS WE'VE ALREADY
SEEN SUCCESS OF OUR EFFORTS.
WHICH IS PROOF THAT THE WATER
USAGE HAS BEEN ON A STEADY
DECLINE THE CURRENT MEDIUM WATER
USAGES FORTY EIGHT GALLONS PER
CAPITA DAILY. AND THAT IS WELL
BELOW THE TWENTY TWENTY STANDARD
WHICH IS CURRENTLY IN STATUTE.
SOME SAY THIS IS GOING TO BE
COSTLY IS GOING TO COST THE TOP.
WELL THAT'S- LET ME. THAT
THERE'S NOTHING LESS. THAN
CONSERVATION THE SAME ARGUMENTS
ARE MET TIME AND TIME AND TIME
AGAIN WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN YOU
RUN OUT OF WATERWHAT'S THE COST
WHEN YOU RUN INTO WATER TO
SOCIETY TO EVERY OTHER ASPECT OF
OUR LIFE. WE HAVE TO SET THE
STANDARDS TOO CAN. TO CONSERVE
GOING FORWARD INTO THE FUTURE.
AND IF THE STATE DOESN'T SET
THOSE STANDARDS. AND WE DON'T
DETERMINE WHAT CONSERVATION
OFFICIALS SHE MEANS AS I SUGGEST
WE WILL BE EVEN BIGGER TROUBLE
BECAUSE CLIMATE CHANGE HAS
THROWN ALL OF THE RULES OUT OF
THE WINDOW. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MEASURE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
DALLAS. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO JUST PUT
OUT SOME FACTS. TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN THE LAST TWO MONTHS OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND THE
FIRST THREE MONTHS OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. WHERE THE
WETTEST. PERIOD OF TIME IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR STATE. SINCE
WE'VE BEEN KEEPING RECORDS. THE
OROVILLE DAM SPILLWAY BROKE
YOU'LL RECALL THAT THAT WAS THE
WETTEST TIME OF THE YEAR NOW
LOOK THIS DEBATE IS NOT ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE THIS IS ABOUT
WHAT WE COULD DO. IN CLIMATE
CHANGE AND HOW AREWE GOING TO.
TAKE CARE OF CALIFORNIANS. THIS
STATE HAS NOT BUILT ANY NEW
WATER STORAGE SINCE THE SIXTIES
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE OR BILL THEM
. NOW WE HAVE FOLKS WHO DON'T
WANT TO PUT. DAMS ON RIVERS AND
THAT'S FINE WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD SITES
RESERVOIR WHICH WAS ALLOCATED IN
THE PROP ONE BONDS BUT IT'S NOT
BEEN BUILT AND WE HAVE LITERALLY
MILLIONS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN OUR BUDGET RIGHT NOW WE
SHOULD BE BUILDING. THE OFF SITE
THE SITES RESERVOIR OFF STREAM
STORAGE PROJECT WHICH BENEFITS.
FISH AND THE HABITAT IF IT IF
IT'S FARMS IT BIT FITS UNIT
MUNICIPALITIES AND QUITE FRANKLY
WILL REORGANIZE THE DELTA SO WE
CAN USE THE WATER MORE
EFFICIENTLY. WE TALK ABOUT
CONCERT CONCERT CONSERVATION.
YOU CAN ONLY CONSERVE SO MUCH
WATER. WE HAVE DOUBLE THE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
NEED TO BUILD MORE STORAGE AND
THE BIGGEST RESERVOIR IN THE
STATE IS NOT. SHASTA OR OR OR
BILL OR MORE FULSOME DAMS THE
BIGGEST RESERVOIR IS THE
SIERRAS. WHERE THE ABOVE THOSE
DAMS ARE THE WATERSHEDS THAT
FEED THOSE LEGS AND FEET ARE
RIVERS. LAST YEAR THE DIXIE FIRE
THE LARGEST FIRE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BURNED ALMOST A
MILLION ACRES THAT'S THE
WATERSHED THAT FEEDS OR BILL. WE
NEEDED A GOOD CONSERVATION IN
OUR FOREST WE NEED TO BE
THINNING ARE FORCED TO THE FIRE
CAN GO THROUGH AND ALLOW THAT
WATER TO BE CAPTURED AND STORED
IN OUR IN OUR MEADOWS AND COME
OUT INTO OUR STREAMS LATER AT A
LATER TIME OF THE YEAR SO I JUST
WANT TO SHARE THAT YOU KNOW WE
TALK ABOUT COMMERCE CONSERVATION
IN THIS. IN THIS LEGISLATURE
EVERY DAY BUT WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT CREATING NEW WATER AND
MORE WATER. YOU CAN ONLY
CONSERVE SO MUCH. WE WENT FROM
WHATEVER IT WAS SIXTY GALLONS A
DAY TO FORTY EIGHT. THE NEXT
MOVE WILL BE. THIRTY FIVE BUT AT
SOME POINT YOU HAVE TO CREATE
NEW WATER THE POPULATION IS
GROWING IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
NEED TO BUILD MORE RESERVOIRS
AND BE SMART WITH OUR
ENVIRONMENT. DURING CLIMATE
CHANGE. THOSE REASON I ASKED FOR
A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL WE NEED
TO BE BUILDING STORAGE. THANK
YOU SENATOR NELSON. MR PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
A YES VOTE CONTINENTS'S AND
CONTINUES TO PROMOTE FAILED
POLICIES OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. FAILED POLICIES ON
WATER WHAT DO I MEAN. FOR THESE
DECADES OUR WHOLE WATER POLICIES
BEEN PREDICATED ON THE SHARING
OF THE SCARCITY LIKEWISE HAS OUR
ENERGY POLICIES SHARING OF
SCARCITY. THAT'S NOT GOING TO
GET US INTO THE FUTURE FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR GRANDCHILDREN.
YOU ARE BE QUIZZING THEM MORE
DROUGHT BECAUSE YOU ARE RELYING
ON CONSERVATION FOR EVERYTHING.
AGAIN WE HAVE NOT BUILT NEW
STORAGE CAPACITY. BUT TEN YEARS
AGO THIS LEGISLATURE DID PASS
PROPOSITION ONE AND THE VOTERS
OVERWHELMINGLY PASSED
PROPOSITION ONE. WHAT WAS IN THE
PARK AND PROPOSITION ONE. TWO
POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR A NEW LARGE SURFACE STORAGE
. TEN YEARS LATER AND ANOTHER
SEVERE DROUGHT NOT ONE SHOVEL
HAS BEEN TURNED. WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PEARL. THERE
AGENCIES. AND I GUESS THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA HAVEN'T COMPLAINED
ABOUT. AND THE REGULATORY
AGENCIES OF THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE BILL
LABOR THE PROCESS. SO WE TEN
YEARS LATER HAVE NOT STORED A
GALLON OF WATER. INSIGHT'S
RESERVOIR WHICH WAS THE CHOSEN
RESERVOIR FOR THAT FUNDING THERE
WERE OTHER. DID UP EXPENDITURES
BUT THAT'S THE MAIN ONE. NOW THE
WATER COMMISSION JUST PUT IN A
MEASLY BILLION OR SO DOLLARS
GOOD FOR THEM. BUT THIS IS BEEN
AROUND FOR TEN YEARS. AND FOR
TEN YEARS ACTUALLY FOR LONGER
THAN THAT. THE FIFTY SOME YEARS
WE'VE SHARED SCARCITY OR THAT
GET. DID THAT HELP YOUR
CONSTITUENTS KNOW THEY ARE NOW
BEING ASKED TO TIGHTEN. THE
FAUCETS EVEN MORE SO TWO OR
THREE OR FOUR OR FIVE YEARS FROM
NOW WE'LL HAVE ANOTHER DROUGHT.
YES WE WILL LIVE FARM TO FIVE OF
THE NIGHTLIFE. WE'LL HAVE
ANOTHER DROUGHT. SO WHAT ARE WE
GONNA CALL GOING TO CONSERVE
MORE WATER ARE GOING TO STORE
MORE WATER EXCESS WATER THAT
COMES DOWN FROM THIS YEAR'S. NO
NO WE'RE GONNA CONSERVE BECAUSE
THAT'S A BOLD THING TO DO THAT'S
THE ONE THING TO DO THAT'S A
GOOD THING TO DO. WELL FOLKS IT
HASN'T WORKED. LET'S ADMIT THAT. LET'S MOVE ON AND PUT YOUR
PRESSURE. ON THE AGENCIES OF
GOVERNMENT. TO PERMIT THE
BUILDING OF A RESERVOIR IN
COLUSA COUNTY. NOW. WHAT DID
THIS LEGISLATURE RECENTLY DO THE
OPPOSITE I HAD A SIMPLE BILL.
SIMPLY IS TRYING TO INCREASE.
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR LARGE
SURFACE STORAGE TO ENCOURAGE
MOVING FORWARD WITH SITES
RESERVOIR THE VERY FIRST
COMMITTEE IN THIS HOUSE KILL THE
BILL. HOLDEN SAID. NO TO STORAGE
AND THOSE NO VOTES SAID THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA TIGHTEN
YOUR FAUCETS MORE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T CARE ABOUT
YOU. THAT'S WHAT THAT MEANT. NOW
SOME OF US AND THOSE WHO ARE
SPEAKING LOUDER HERE TODAY ARE
THOSE WHO REPRESENT THE AREAS
WHERE THE WATER COMES FROM. AND
WHAT IS HAPPENED IN THOSE AREAS
WELL. FOR DECADES OUR POLICIES
IN FORCE AND WILDLANDS IS TO
LOCK THEM UP DON'T DO ANYTHING
WITH THEM. RESULT CATACLYSMIC
FIRES THE NOW MOVED INTO THE BIG
CITIES- BOARD NOW WE WAKE UP NOW
WE'VE GOT A PROBLEM. NOW WE'RE
GONNA PUT A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY
INTO FOREST AND WILDLAND
MANAGEMENT. WELL I SUBMIT I TOOK
SOME OF US. NOT TO PARADISE IF
YOU YEARS AGO TO SEE THE RAVAGES
OF THE FIRE. WELL THE FIRES HAVE
A IMPACTED SOME DON'T EVEN THINK
ABOUT. WE'RE DRIVING ALONG THE
BUS. AND LOOKED OUT THE WINDOW
AND THERE WAS A LARGE. WHILE THE
BOARD. THERE BARBECUED NOT ON
THE SPIRIT. BUT IN A FIRE. WHAT
IS THE POINT WHERE THESE FIRES
DUE TO THE WILDLIFE. DESTROYS
BOB ASKED SOME FOLKS DELIVER
SEEN A SQUIRREL EXPLODE. I HAVE
. THAT'S KIND OF HARSH BUT
THAT'S THE REALITY THE WILDLIFE
GO UP IN FLAMES AS DOES THEIR
HABITAT. THAT HABITAT ALSO HAS A
GREAT IMPACT ON THE WATERSHED IN
THE STORAGE CAPACITY OF THOSE
WATERSHEDS. AND THE ABILITY TO
UTILIZE THE EXCESS WATER. IF WE
HAD SOME STORAGE CAPACITY. THE
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN VOTE NO ON
THE PAST FAILED POLICIES. AND
LET'S SEND A SIGNAL. THAT WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON STORAGE
CAPACITY AND MANAGING OUR
FORESTS AND WILDLANDS FOR THE
SAKE OF COURSE THE FIRES AND THE
DISASTERS THEY BEQUEATH. END THE
RAVAGES OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
HAVE SUFFICIENT WATER. AND WHEN
YOU VOTE. THANK ABOUT YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN. ONE LAST EXAMPLE. TEN YEARS AGO WERE NEGOTIATING
AND GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER'S
OFFICE AT TWO O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING. ON PROP ONE. AND I'M
LISTENING TO THE MEMBERSHIP
THERE SITTING AND TALKING.
TALKING ABOUT THEMSELVES TALKING
ABOUT THE NEXT ELECTION. AND THE
IMPACT THAT THIS MEASURE MIGHT
HAVE IN THE NEXT ELECTION. THEN
AFTER BEING FRUSTRATED TWO
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING LISTENING
TO THIS BLADDER. I SAID DON'T
YOU GET IT. THIS IS NOT ABOUT
YOU THIS IS NOT ABOUT NOW. THIS
IS ABOUT YOUR GRAND CHILDREN.
THEN I LOOKED AROUND THAT WHOLE
TABLE. INCLUDING A GOVERNOR AND
THE BLACK CLUTCH TOLD MEALL I
NEEDED TO KNOW THAT WAS NOT ON
THEIR MINDS. THANK YOU HAVE A
BOOK YES. YOUR GRANDCHILDREN ARE
NOT ON YOUR MINDS I URGE A NOBLE
. THANK YOU SENATOR BORCHERS.
NOT EASY FOLLOWING THE CENTER
FOR FROM TAMAR. ON THIS TOPIC. I
THINK SOME FOLKS THAT- THE MAYBE
REPRESENT AREAS THAT DO NOT HAVE
AGRICULTURE OR DID NOT HAVE
WILDFIRES OR OTHER DIRECT
IMPACTS- PERHAPS HAVE SRATCHED
THEIR HEADS ON WHY THIS- IGNITES
THE IRE OF FOLKS FROM- THE
INTERIOR OF CALIFORNIA SPECIAL.
FOLKS I THINK WE HAVE A
CREDIBILITY PROBLEM IN THIS
CHAMBER IN FACT IN THIS BUILDING
. WE HAVE A HISTORY OF VOTING
FOR THINGS. AND THEN NOT DOING.
WE HAVE A HISTORY OF PUTTING
THINGS OUT TO THE VOTERS.
GENERATING THE PR IN THE
MACHINERY THAT WILL ALLOW THINGS
TO PASS AND THEN DELIBERATELY
USING THE INSTRUMENTS OF STATE.
DO NOT ALLOW THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS TO BE AFFECTED. IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN PROP ONE WAS PASSED.
HOW LONG HAS IT BEEN SINCE THEN
. IN THIS YET NOTHING WAS DONE.
THE GOAL POSTS HAVE BEEN MOVED
BY THE RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES
ON WHETHER OR NOT ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS OF TODAY ARE EXACTLY
LIKE THOSE BACK IN THE DAY WHEN
THAT THE MATTER WAS FIRST
REVIEWED SO IN SHORT THE
INSTRUMENTS AND DIVISIONS IN IN
ORGANIZATIONS OF THE STATE HAVE
FOUND WAYS TO OBFUSCATE THE WILL
OF THE VOTERS. THIS IS A
CREDIBILITY PROBLEM WHEN
LEGISLATURES LIKE US. BANCED A
BILL IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF
CALIFORNIANS PROBABLY KNOWING
THERE WILL NEVER BE AN AFFECTION
WE XIN OF THAT OUTCOME. THIS IS
DISHEARTENING IN THE GIVES US A
CREDIBILITY PROBLEM. NOW WE
HEARD FROM THE AUTHOR OF THIS OF
THIS BILL CONSERVATION IS
ESSENTIAL AND I WOULD I WOULD
VENTURE TO SAY CONSERVATION IS
DEFINITELY PART OF PART OF THE-
PART THE CALCULUS HERE. WE ALSO
HEARD THAT THE AVERAGE USAGES
FORTY EIGHT GALLONS PER PERSON
PER DAY. WHICH IS BASICALLY IN
LINE WITH WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
WITH THIS NEW PROPOSAL RIGHT
NOW. SO I DON'T KNOW TO WHAT TO
WHAT EFFECT THIS WILL ACTUALLY
YIELD. BUT I WOULD CAUTION THE
AUTHOR IN IN SUPPORTERS THEY'RE
GOING TO TRY PROBABLY IN THE
CLOSING STATEMENTS TO
DISTINGUISH. CONSERVATION FROM
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD OUT. THEY
ARE TWO SIDES OF THE SAME COIN
YOU CAN'T CONSERVE OUR WAY OUT
UNLESS YOU BUILT. IN CONCERT.
CENTER NIELSEN IT'S TO BE THE
CENTER FROM TO HIM AND I HAD A
BILL IT WAS SHOT DOWN THE FIRST
COMMITTEE AND IT WAS SIMPLY TO
GET A FACT TO MONEY THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN APPROPRIATED BY THE
VOTERS TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
SITES RESERVOIR MOVES FORWARD AS
WELL AS CONVENIENCE AND OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR VALLEY. HOW
INTELLECTUALLY DISHONEST CAN WE
BE TO VOTE DOWN TO SOMETHING THE
VOTERS APPROVED. THIS IS THE
EPITOME OF HYPOCRISY. AND WE DO
OR WE DO OUR BEST TO BUILD
COLLEGIALITY IN THIS IN THIS IN
THIS BUILDING TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT OUR WORD MEANS SOMETHING.
BUT MY CONCERN. AND IT'S NOT
THIS BILL IT IS THE TOPIC OF
WATER IN BILL THE LACK OF
COMMITMENT TO EFFECTUATE THE
WILL OF THE VOTERS IN THE NEEDS
OF OUR STATE FOR TODAY AND
TOMORROW. THAT WHEN WE ALLOW ME
ALLOW THIS TO HAPPEN AND WE
SEGREGATE AND WE
COMPARTMENTALIZE AND WE
SEPARATE. WHAT IS ESSENTIALLY A
DYNAMIC ISSUE REQUIRING A
MULTISECTOR APPROACH THAT WE'RE
NOT BEING HONEST WE ONLY TAKE A
SLIVER HERE AND PUT IT IN THE
REALM OF CONSERVATION.
COLLEAGUES I IMPLORE YOU. THIS
IS NOT A NORMAL BILL THIS IS NOT
A NORMAL TOPIC. I'M AFRAID THAT
WE'RE GOING TO END THIS
LEGISLATIVE YEAR AND MAYBE THE
ONES FOLLOWING WITHOUT DOING THE
HARD WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
. ATMOSPHERE FOR POLITICAL
SPECIAL INTERESTS- OF REDOUBLE
LECTION OUTCOMES FEAR OF THE
POLITICAL FORCES THAT MAY OR MAY
NOT EXIST THAT BEAR ON POLITICAL
FORTUNES. BUT WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING AND WE SAID WE'RE
GOING TO DO IT BUT WHERE IS IT
WE HAVEN'T BUILT ANYTHING YET WE
HAVEN'T INVESTED IN CONVEYANCE
OF THE CANAL SYSTEM WERE DEALT
WITH THE SUBSIDENCE ISSUES.
COLLEAGUES AND I'LL CONCLUDE
HERE. THIS IS A CONSERVATION
ISSUE AND WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM THE AUTHORING CLOSING DON'T
CONFLATE. BUT FRANKLY IT NEEDS
TO BE A PART OF THE DISCUSSION.
AND I WOULD ASK YOU TO PUSH THIS
OFF AS AN ISSUE EVEN VOTE NO
TODAY AS AN ISSUE. TO FORCE US
TO TAKE THE NEXT STEPS TO DEAL
WITH THIS WATER ISSUE THAT
INCLUDES STORAGE CONVEYANCING
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS AS WELL
AS CONSERVATION. THANK YOU
SENATOR MATT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I ANT TO COMMEND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY FOR PUTTING FOR THIS
BILL- WE ARE FACING A CLIMATE
CRISIS WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO
ADAPT TO THE CHANGES THAT WE
KNOW ARE HERE AND ONE OF THOSE
CHANGES UNFORTUNATELY IS THE
CYCLE OF DROUGHT THAT WE'RE
FACING RIGHT NOW I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE COST OF THIS
THE PACE OF THIS- I'VE HEARD
FROM A NUMBER OF MY LOCAL WATER
DISTRICTS- BUT I KNOW THAT MY
VALLEY- IS COMMITTED TO MAKING
THIS BILL RIGHT TO ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
OPPOSITION SO- WITH THAT IN MIND
WITH KNOWING HIS HISTORY OF. OF
HARD WORK OF WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION OF WORKING TO MAKE
HIS BILLS RIGHT I AM TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL DATES ARE THANK YOU.
THANK YOUS. SENATOR OFF. THANK
YOU- MISTER PRESIDENT I WANT TO
BE SURE TO MAKE SURE. MY VIEWS
KNOWN AND I WANT TO. STAND ON
THE RECORD IS OF CERTAINLY
SUPPORTING CONSERVATION. BUT I
ALSO SHARE THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY MY COLLEAGUES FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO SECURE MORE. WATER
RESOURCES WHATEVER THOSE ARE AND
WE WERE FRANKLY NEED TO DO THEM
NOW. I DON'T SIT ON THE
COMMITTEES IN THIS HOUSE THEN
HERE THOSE SORTS OF MEASURES.
BUT I CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE
EFFORTS TO EXPLORE WHY
ADDITIONAL WATER RESOURCES HAVE
NOT BEEN SECURED AND TO PUSH FOR
THOSE FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DO
SIT ON THOSE COMMITTEES. I DON'T
THINK THESE ISSUES ARE MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE- AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE EVERYBODY KNOWS MY
VIEW ON THAT I'M I'M SURE THAT
THOSE FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. I HOPE SHARE
THOSE VIEWS SO WE SHOULD DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN DO IN
THIS HOUSE TO PUSH FOR
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE
ADDITIONAL WATER RESOURCES IN
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THOSE
RESOURCES IN THE STATE AND WE
SHOULD DO SO NOW. BUT AS I SAID
THE ISSUES ARE NOT. MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE WE DO NOT HAVE A WATER
STORAGE BILL BEFORE US TODAY. SO
WITH REGARD TO THIS BILL I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT I KNOW TO
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY THE WATER
DISTRICTS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND IN PARTICULAR
THOSE. THAT SIT IN THE THIRTY
FIRST SENATE DISTRICT- I TRUSTED
MY COLLEAGUE FROM. THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY WILL TAKE THOSE
CONCERNS. AND KEEP THEM IN MIND
SHOULD THIS BILL PASS OFF THE
FLOOR TODAY AND AS IT MOVES
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE. AND TRY
AND ADDRESS THE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE IMPACT ON THE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE IN REDUCTION. IN
WATER USE NO QUESTION WE NEED TO
REDUCE THE WATER USE BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE- TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THE IMPACT ON OUR
LOCAL WATER DISTRICTS. HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO FUND THE
CHANGES IN THEIR OPERATIONS THAT
ARE NECESSARY AND OCCASIONED BY.
THE WATER OR THE REDUCTION IN
WATER USE THE BADLY NEEDED WATER
PRODUCTION WATER USE IN THIS
STATE. BUT NEVERTHELESS IT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES I WONDER RISE AS
THE CHAIR THE WATER COMMITTEE-
WITH GREAT RESPECT FOR THE CHAIR
EMERITUS OF THE WATER COMMITTEE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. AND JUST GET
SOME FACTS STRAIGHT HERE ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IF
WE'RE- MAKING PRESUMPTIONS ABOUT
CREDIBILITY- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE FUTURE AS SOME FORM OF
NOSTALGIA THAT SUDDENLY
CALIFORNIANS GOING TO LOOK LIKE
IT USED TO. IN THE NEXT TEN AND
TWENTY YEARS WE'RE LIVING IN A
FANTASY WORLD. THE THOUGHT THAT
THE RAINS WILL JUST COME BACK
FOR BECAUSE IT WAS A AWAY YEAR
LAST YEAR ALSO MEANS THAT THE
DROUGHT ISN'T HAMMERING OUR
COMMUNITIES. IS SO AT ODDS WITH
WHAT'S HAPPENING IT IS GOING TO
BE WIDER THAN FLOOD MORE. AND
WE'RE IS GOING TO BE DRIER AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE MORE SEVERE
DROUGHTS THOSE TWO IN THIS
CLIMATE ERA THAT GREAT SNAPBACK
. IT'S HAPPENING RIGHT BEFORE
OUR EYES AND SO I JUST I'M SO
INCREDULOUS BECAUSE WHEN WE AS
URBAN WATER USERS GO TO TIGHTEN
OUR BELTS AND I THINK THIS IS AN
ENORMOUS ACT OF SELF SACRIFICE
FOR THE HEART OF URBAN WATER
USE. IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
TO BE STEPPING AND SAY WE'RE
GONNA DO OUR PART. WE WANT TO
PUT OUR EFFICIENCY ON THE TABLE
AND SAY WILL STEP UP. AND THOSE
WHO WANT SUPPLY ELSEWHERE
SAYING. WELL WHY WOULD YOU
TIGHTEN YOUR BELTS. THAT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
BUILDING A DAM SOMEWHERE ELSE
THAT'S NOT EVEN SHOVEL READY.
BUT WE'VE GOT TO BE A LITTLE
MORE SOBER ABOUT HOW WE APPROACH
THE WATER CONVERSATION THIS
ISN'T A PLACE FOR POSTURE THIS
IS A LACE FOR DELIVERING. THE
SENATE DELIVERED LAST YEAR IN
ITS BUDGET ON ITS DROUGHT
PACKAGE AND WE'RE GONNA BE
DOUBLING DOWN ON THAT I
GUARANTEE YOU IT'S HAPPENING
THIS YEAR I HAVE. UTTER
CONFIDENCE IN MY COLLEAGUES TO
GET. THIS WORK DONE BUT I WOULD
CAUTION AGAINST ANY SOFTENING
HERE. YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND IS
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE WE
STRUGGLE BECAUSE THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY A COMPROMISE. THIS BILL
WALKS BACK WHAT WHAT LEGISLATION
LAST YEAR WOULD HAVE DONE IN
RATCHETING DOWN THE EFFICIENCY
STANDARDS IN URBAN USE. TO FORTY
EIGHT GALLONS PER DAY. THIS IS
ONLY FIFTY FIVE GALLONS PER DAY
WHAT CURRENT LOSSES UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. WE'RE NOT ASKING
ANYONE TO DO THIS WORK RIGHT NOW
BUT IF WE CAN'T SOLVE OVER OUR
WAY THROUGH SOME ADDITIONAL
SEWER GAS THAT GETS BUILT UP
BECAUSE WE'RE BEING MORE
EFFICIENT OR THE INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES WE NEED BECAUSE- MAYBE
YOU'RE NOT. PUSHING AS MUCH OUT
OF YOUR SHOWERS. OR YOUR HOUSES
THROUGH URBAN WATER USE AND IT'S
NOT GOING TO THE WASTE WATER
TREATMENT PLANT. THERE ARE
THINGS THAT CAN BE SOLVED HERE
WE CAN ENGINEER OUR WAY THROUGH
THIS BUT- IF WE DON'T EVEN HAVE
SPACE TO HOLD OURSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE IN THE URBAN AREAS
OF. OF CALIFORNIA. I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD HERE SO. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IN AND I ALSO RESPECT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL AND
TREMENDOUS RESPECT FOR THE
AUTHOR BY IN EVERY HEADLINE THAT
HE I HAVE READ ON. IS VERY
CONCERNING VERY REAL AND I KNOW
THAT- WE DEFINITELY HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT. THE CRISIS I
ESPECIALLY AS IT PERTAINS TO
WATER CONSERVATION AND SETTING
NEW STANDARDS ARE CRITICAL.
HOWEVER FOR ME IT'S A LITTLE.
DIFFERENT AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
IN ORDER TO GET THIS DONE WE
HAVE TO. INVOLVE OUR LOCAL WATER
AGENCIES SO THAT'S WHERE MY
CONCERN LIES THAT WE'RE PUTTING
A TREMENDOUS BURDEN. FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON THESE LOCAL AGENCIES
AND IT'S NOT ABOUT GIVING ANYONE
A PASS BUT IT'S ABOUT GIVING
THEM TIME AND ALLOWING THEM TO
COME TO THE TABLE AND- AND RIGHT
NOW I JUST DON'T SEE THE ODDS
ARE I WANT TO RECONSIDER THE
BILL LATER ON AS THE
CONVERSATIONS MOVE BUT- YOU KNOW
I UNDERSTAND AT A LOCAL LEVEL
HOW. MUCH THIS IS GOING TO PUT
ON THEM AND SO AGAIN I WANT TO
BE SUPPORTIVE IN THE FUTURE WHEN
THESE CONVERSATIONS CONTAIN.
THIS POINT I WILL HAVE TO LAY
OFF YEAH- THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION INNOVATION- DOT. A
YES MISTER- THIS PRESENT I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK I KNOW WERE TRYING TO MOVE
ON HERE I'M JUST GONNA SO SAVE
MY COMMENTS WITH US SENATOR ROTH
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT-
TO THE- THE DEAN OF THE SENATE
FROM- HEY MATT THANK YOU. YOU
KNOW YOU SAY A MEASLY BILLION
DOLLARS WAS ALLOCATED SITES
RESERVOIR I'M AS FRUSTRATED AS
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM THAT SITES
RESERVOIR IS NOT ALREADY BUILT.
YOUR FRANKLY I THINK THAT'S
GOING TO BE WHAT IS GOING TO BE
BUILT BECAUSE THERE IS A BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT. THE BUILD AND
YOU HAVE THE PROPOSITION WHEN IT
WAS PASSED WAS SET UP TO SET UP
THIS COMMISSION THAT IT WOULD DO
IT TWO DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATIONS
HAVE BEEN SUPPORTING THAT IT'S
WHERE WE ARE NOW AND I WOULD
SAY. THAT WE ARE GOING FOR I
REALLY DO BELIEVE THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO VAST ABILITY AND
DOLLARS INSIGHTS RESERVOIR ONLY
TO BLOW THAT AND NOT HAVE IT
HAPPEN I THINK IT'S ON ITS WAY.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE CAN
WALK. TALK INTO GO AND DO
THINGS- ON THE OTHER SIDE
CONSERVATION WISE AND SO I ASKED
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR CALM WATER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW- I DON'T
BELIEVE IN EXPLODING SQUIRRELS
BUT WHAT I DO BELIEVE IN IS THAT
WE HAVE A FINITE NATURAL
RESOURCE AND WATER AND A PLANET
THAT IS ASKING US TO LIVE IN
REALITY ABOUT WHAT IS AT STAKE.
SO MY DISTRICT IS NOT AN
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT AND I
ACTUALLY WASN'T PLANNING TO
SPEAK ON THIS BILL. BUT WE DO
USE WATER IN THE THIRTY S.
SENATE DISTRICT AND AS A STATE
WE NEED TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT
WATER USAGE CONSERVATION.
RECLAMATION AND HOW TO HELP US
MANAGE THIS DWINDLING RESOURCE.
YOU CAN'T CONSERVE UNLESS YOU'RE
ALSO TALKING ABOUT MANAGING
CONSUMPTION THAT'S JUST A
REALITY. WE NEED A STATE WIDE
CAPITAL INFRASTRUCTURE STRATEGY
THAT DOES INCLUDE WATER. WE
REALLY DO BECAUSE HOW WE USE IT
VARIES FROM THE TIP OF THE STATE
TO THE BOTTOM. BUT UNTIL WE GET
THERE THIS REALLY IS A RATIONAL
AND MEASURED BILL THAT WILL
HOPEFULLY JUMPSTART THE KINDS OF
ROBUST AND IMMEDIATE AND DIRE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
ABOUT WATER IN OUR LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT AND VOTE I FOR
SB ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU
SENATOR CAFIERO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I TO DO- DIDN'T INTEND
TO STAND UP AND TALK TODAY BUT-
MOSTLY BECAUSE I WASN'T IN
SUPPORT HI FRANKLY BUT- I AM.
AND I WANT TO TELL YOU WHY SO
THAT- HOPEFULLY WE CAN WORK ON
THE BIGGER PICTURE I GOTTA TELL
YOU I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY WHAT- ARE CALLING
FROM- BIEBER SAID. IT IS IT'S
FRUSTRATING TO SEE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN THAT
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO CONSERVE ON ONE HAND BUT THEN
ALSO TO TAKE CARE OF SOME OF THE
OTHER ISSUES THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE WATER. AND THAT
THAT OUR STATE CAN DROUGHT PROOF
ITSELF AND THAT WE DON'T END UP
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS IN
THE WATER WAR I'M SO THE BIG
PICTURE IS I THINK WE NEED- WE
NEED WE REALLY NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO PUT
OUR RESOURCES INTO. RECYCLING TO
ABOUT CAPTURING THESE- FLOOD
YEARS THAT THAT HAPPENED IN IN
OUR REGION CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
TO TAKE THAT WATER AND- SAVE IT
UP BUT BUT I ALSO. AM FRUSTRATED
THAT WHEN THE STATE GETS TO A
DROUGHT THE DIFFERENT REGIONS
ARE ASKED TO DO DIFFERENT THINGS
DESPITE THE FACT THAT TWO THIRDS
OF OUR RESIDENTS. TAKE WATER
FROM THE DELTA. SO IF TO OF OUR
TO OUR RESIDENTS ARE TAKING
WATER FROM THE DELTA AND WE HAVE
A DROUGHT THAT EVERYBODY SHOULD
BE TOLD YOU YOU HAVE TO CONSERVE
AND THAT MEANS. PUTTING
MANDATORY CONSERVATION-
OBLIGATIONS ON EVERYONE AND TO
DO IT BY REGION TO ME JUST
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE BECAUSE
FRANKLY IT ALWAYS ENDS UP
HITTING THE CENTRAL ALLEY THAT
YOU GOT IT. YOU GET NOTHING IN
YOU'VE GOT TO CONSERVE TO BUT IN
REGARDS TO YOUR PARTICULAR. BELL
HERE'S WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
AND YOU NEED TO KNOW THAT ALL
THE WATER AGENCY OR ARE OPPOSED
AND I TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY THE
CONCERNS. IF YOU DO A PER CAPITA
- ANALYSIS THEN THE P. THE
RESIDENCES THAT TO AFFECT THE
MOST ARE THOSE THAT ARE THE
POOREST AND IT'S BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE POOR. AND YOU ON. BUT IN
MY REGION IF YOU'RE POOR AND
YOUR AN AGRICULTURAL WORKER YOU
USUALLY HAVE. MANY MANY ADULTS
LIVING IN IN THAT UNIT AND SO
THERE'S A SOME SHINS THAT THE
WATER COMPANIES USE THAT SAY
THERE'S TWO ADULTS AND TWO
CHILDREN RIGHT IN IT IN A TWO
BEDROOM. UNIT IN IN IN MY REGION
ARE EXPERIENCES THAT COULD BE
TEN ADULTS AND FOUR CHILDREN AND
SO YOU GET A WATER ALLOCATION
AND IF YOU IF YOU USE MORE THAN
THAT YOU GET. A PENALTY.
ANYTHING OVER THAT ALLOCATION
YOU PAY MORE FOR AND SO THE
REGION WHEN WE DID THIS PER
CAPITA ANALYSIS OR ARE IN
POSITION. THE LAST DROUGHT. IN
IN MY AREA THE PEOPLE THAT WERE
REALLY HURT WHERE WERE THE
POOREST AND SO I'M I'M VERY
CONCERNED WITH WITH HOW THIS
GETS- DETERMINED WE LEAVE IT UP
TO THE WATER WE TELL THEM THIS
IS WHAT WE WANT YOU TO DO WE
LEAVE IT UP TO THE WATER COMPANY
AND IT WAS. ABOUT IN MY MIND IT
WAS- ABUSIVE ABUSIVELY USED
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO WAY FOR
PEOPLE TO FILE A APPEAL. FOR TO
KNOW WHAT THEY COULD DO IF THEY
WERE ASSESSED A HIGHER WATER
RATES UP BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY
THAT THE COMPANY HAD SET UP
THEIR PROGRAM. AND THE STATE
DIDN'T HAVE A WAY TO GO BACK AND
TELL THEM YOU YOU DETRIMENTALLY
HURT POOR PEOPLE IN- IN
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM AND SO
YOU HAVE TO MAKE IT RIGHT SO
THAT'S- AYE THAT'S MY BIGGEST
CONCERN ABOUT IT WE NEED TO BE
FAIR- AND HOPEFULLY THIS
LEGISLATURE WILL LOOK AT. MORE
BROADER SOLUTIONS. ABSOLUTELY NO
QUESTION WE HAVE TO CONSERVE-
AND SOME AREAS ARE DOING A
REALLY GOOD JOB BUT WE ALSO NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES IN- IN RESIDENTIAL
YOU UNITS AND NOT ALL OF THEM
ARE EQUAL SO. THANK YOU WITHOUT
I WOULDN'T RECOMMEND IT I BOUGHT
. THANK YOU SENATOR TARA. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I TO WAS NOT
GOING TO SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE BUT
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE BECAUSE OF
ALL THE IMPACTS THAT. AND THE
SHORTAGES OF WATER THAT WE HAVE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND-
BILLION I WANT TO SPEAK TO IT.
IN IN TERMS OF THE BIG PICTURE
RIGHT I THINK THIS IS. THE
GREATEST CHALLENGE FACING
MANKIND TODAY. WATER SCARCITY
WATER SECURITY. YOU SEE WATER
SECURITY MEANS MUCH MORE THAN
JUST WATER AND WATER SECURITY IS
NOT JUST ABOUT CANALS OR STORAGE
ISSUES- EVEN THOUGH IT IS A HUGE
PART OF IT. OUR WATER SECURITY
IS ALSO A HUMAN SECURITY ISSUE.
IMPACTS OF POOR WATER MANAGEMENT
IN CALIFORNIA THREATEN THE
SAFETY AND WELLBEING OF ALL
PEOPLE. I'M MORE CONCERNING IT
THREATENS OUR DEMOCRACY AND OUR
VERY OWN EXISTENCE. LET ME SAY
THAT AGAIN POOR WATER MANAGEMENT
THREATENS OUR DEMOCRACY AND OUR
VERY OWN EXISTENCE. WATER
INSECURITY CAN AND WILL LEAD TO
SOCIAL DISRUPTION IF LEFT
UNFIXED AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING I
JUST KIND OF THREW OUT THERE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY. I
WAS PUT IN IN THE MOST RECENT-
IPCC REPORT BACK IN FEBRUARY.
AND SO WE MUST DO EVERYTHING
THAT WE CAN TO MAKE THIS MOMENT
. ABOUT WE REALLY HAVE TO LOOK
AT WATER BEYOND CALIFORNIA AND
YES CONSERVATIONISTS. BUT PART
OF IT. BUT WE REALLY HAVE TO
LOOK AT THE OTHER WAYS THAT WE
MUST PROTECT THE LIMITED WATER
THAT WE HAVE. BECAUSE THAT IS
ALSO ON THE LINE AND I WANT TO
BE ABLE TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE ONE
OF THE REPORTS THAT CAME OUT
BACK IN TWENTY TWELVE. ON THE
GLOBAL WATER SECURITY- THE STATE
AT EIGHT IT CONFIRM THREE
DIFFERENT THINGS ONE WATER MAYBE
POTENTIALLY USED AS LEVERAGE
OVER NEIGHBORS TO PRESERVE WATER
INTEREST TO WATER MAY BE USED AS
A WEAPON WITH SOME UPSTREAM
NATIONS IMPEDING OR CUTTING OFF
DOWNSTREAM. FLOW TO PRESSURE
POPULATIONS OR SUPPRESS THEM.
THREE WATER MAY BE USED AS A
FORM OF TERRORISM. PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE DAMS WILL
BECOME TARGETS OF TERRORIST. NOW
I KNOW IT SOUNDS LIKE A
HOLLYWOOD. LIKE A SCARY
HOLLYWOOD MOVIE. BUT THE REALITY
IS THAT THIS IS THIS IS THIS IS
A VERY MUCH VERY MUCH A REALITY
HERE AT HOME. AND IT'S- SOMEWHAT
VIDEO TERRORIST ATTEMPTS ARE
ALREADY OCCURRING QUIETLY IN THE
FORM OF CYBER ATTACKS ON ALL
THINGS WATER. WATER IS BEING
USED AS LEVERAGE AT THIS POINT
AND I WANTED. EXPLAIN A LITTLE
BIT AND WHAT THAT MEANS. JUST
LAST YEAR THERE WAS AN ATTACK ON
ONE OF OUR WATER TREATMENT
SYSTEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
THERE ARE CHEMICALS USED TO
TREAT WATER WERE JUST TO DEBT
LEVELS BY A HACKER. FORTUNATELY
THAT THE ADJUSTMENTS WERE
NOTICED BEFORE ANYONE FELL ILL
AND WATER WAS CONTAMINATED. NOW
WITH THE SITUATION IN UKRAINE
RUSSIA IS USING CYBER THREATS AS
A FORM OF LEVERAGE IN MY OPINION
THEY HAVE. ARE THERE WAS A- AB.
THERE'S BEEN EFFORTS IN THE WE
GOT TO REALLY LOOK AT ALL THINGS
WATER WHEN IT COMES TO THE CYBER
ATTACK ATTEMPTS. AND I WANNA
GIVE ANOTHER EXAMPLE IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN IT. A UKRAINIAN HACKER.
ENTERED INTO THE COMMAND CONTROL
SYSTEM OF A DOWN IN THE STATE OF
NEW YORK. LUCKILY THE GATE HAD
BEEN MANUALLY DISCONNECTED FOR
MAINTENANCE THAT DAY. HAD IT NOT
THE DAM WATER WOULD HAVE BEEN
RELEASED SO WE TALK ABOUT WATER
CONVERT AT CONSERVATION I AGREE
WE REALLY NEED TO WE NEED TO
QUANTIFY WATER IN ALL SENSES
RIGHT AND INCLUDING THE
CONSUMPTION THAT WE- THAT THAT
WE WANT TO USE IN OUR OWN HOMES
I THINK THAT'S- THAT'S PART OF
IT BUT I ALSO THINK WE HAVE TO
BE VERY. CAREFUL AND CAUTIOUS
ABOUT. HOW WE APPROACH IT THE
ISSUES THAT ARE IN FRONT OF US
WHEN IT COMES TO WATER BE WE
SHOULD BE PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON.
THE LEAKAGES THAT ARE ALREADY
EXISTED AND THAT'S WHY I YOU
KNOW I SPONSORED SENATE BILL
FIVE FIVE NINE BECAUSE IT WOULD
ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL WATER TO GO
DOWN AND ACROSS THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE STATE. YES A RUN THROUGH
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BUT THIRTY
ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS RELY ON
THAT THAT'S ADDITIONAL A FIX
THAT'S ADDITIONAL WATER MOVED
FOR MORE PEOPLE. FOR MORE
COMMUNITIES FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
I SEE THAT AS A FORM OF
CONSERVATION. AND SO. I THINK
CYBER SECURITY ALSO IT'S
PREVENTATIVE RIGHT TO PROTECT
THE WATER THE VERY LIMITED WATER
THAT WE HAVE TODAY. I THINK WE
GOT TO BE ABLE TO DO ALL THESE
THINGS BEFORE WE EVEN GO AND ASK
. PAUL WHO ARE ALREADY LIMITED
ON WATER TO LIMIT EVEN MORE. AND
WE HAVE A AND I'M JUST THINKING
ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT I
REPRESENT OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WHEN THEY'RE GOING THROUGH A
HUNDRED AND THREE DEGREES. SOME
COMMUNITIES GO WITHOUT WATER OUR
AND WATER IS JUST KINDA EIGHT
NEEDED TO LIVE AND TO SURVIVE SO
IMAGINE HAVING TO ASK A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS GONE WITHOUT
WATER OR HAS VERY LIMITED WATER
IN THE EXTREME HEAT OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. ASKING THEM TO
BE YOU KNOW TO- CONSERVE MORE I
JUST. I THINK IT COULD BE IT
COULD BE A LITTLE UNFAIR WE
GOTTA THINK ABOUT THOSE THINGS
BUT I DO THINK THAT WE MUST DO
MORE. AND I THINK WE CAN DO MORE
BUT WE GOT TO GET IT. WE GOTTA
GET IT RIGHT. SO I WILL BE NOT
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT I
REALLY WANT TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORED. SUPPORT THE BUILT ON
THE ROAD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR GROW. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT HOW TO WAS NOT
INTENDING TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL
BUT I'D LIKE TO JUST COME IN ON
SOME STUFF THAT WAS ALREADY SAID
ON THE FLOOR- IF YOU LOOK AT THE
U. S. EPA REPORTS IT SAYS THAT.
ONE POINT SIX GALLONS TAKES TO
FLUSH TOILETS. THE AUTHOR SAYS
THAT IT DOESN'T AFFECT-
HOUSEHOLD IN USE OUR TOILET
USAGE. BUT IF YOU ONLINE- IF I
LINE MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM. THE SALINAS
AREA. WHO ALSO REPRESENTS PART
OF THE VALLEY- IT DOES BECAUSE
THE ALTHOUGH THIS BILL WILL
AFFECT AGENCIES THESE AGENCIES
WILL PUT. A CAP OR A PRO RATA
SHARE- PER HOUSEHOLD. IN MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SALINAS IS
EXACTLY RIGHT THAT IT AFFECTS
POOR PEOPLE. COMPLETELY
DISPROPORTIONATELY. A
REPRESENTING THE CENTRAL VALLEY
A SPECIFICALLY A LOT OF
FARMWORKERS IN MY COMMUNITY THAT
I'VE FOUGHT HARD. AND FOR. A LOT
OF THINGS THAT THIS BUILDING
OPPOSES. ONE THING COMES TO MIND
WHEN THEY THINK ABOUT- WHEN I
THINK ABOUT BILLS THAT HAVE GONE
TO THIS BUILDING WAS THE-
OVERTIME CUT ON WHICH TO CONFIRM
SIXTY TO FORTY HOURS IN THOSE
FARMWORKERS. EVEN AT MINIMUM
WAGE LOSS THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
A MONTH. AND NOW THESE
FARMWORKERS AND THE PEOPLE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE THE
POOREST PART OF OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE. WILL BE AFFECTED BY THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. BECAUSE
THE WATER AGENCIES WILL
DETERMINE. THAT TWO POINT FIVE
ADULTS AND THREE KIDS ARE FOR
KIDS LIVE IN A TWO BEDROOM UNIT
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM SALINAS
SAID. AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT-
THEY WILL PAY THOSE OVERAGE FEES
ON LESS RESOURCES OR LESS
DISPOSABLE INCOME BECAUSE
THEY'RE PAYING HIGHER COSTS FOR
FUEL. AND HIGHER COSTS FOR
LIVING A GROCERIES AND
EVERYTHING WITH INFLATION. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT UNDER THE U. S.
EPA IT ALSO SAYS THAT IT TAKES
ABOUT FOUR GALLONS. IF YOU HAVE
ANY. TOP OF THE LINE IF FISSION
ENERGY EFFICIENT. TOP OF THE
LINE DISHWASHER. I CAN TELL YOU
THAT A LOT OF THE COMMUNITIES IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SPECIFICALLY
IMPORTER BILL WHERE MIGHT A
COLLEAGUE FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY JUST SPOKE IN SHARES KERN
COUNTY WITH ME. WE HAVE PEOPLE
IMPORTER BILL THAT DON'T HAVE
WATER IN THEIR HOME AND THEY
DELIVERED WATER TO A BIG BLACK
TANK OUTSIDE. THE NAY BUT GIDEON
LIKE IT. LIKE THEY DID WHEN I
WITH THE GUADALAJARA NASTY POT
IN MEXICO WHERE THEY CARRIED THE
WATER ON THEIR HEAD. FROM AT OF
THE MAJOR WATER SOURCE IN THE
CENTER OF TOWN. YEARS AGO WHEN I
WAS A CHILD. SO THEY GET THIS
WATER IT'S DELIVERED ON THESE
BLACK BUT IN THEIR FRONT YARD OF
THESE BIG BLACK TANK. AND THEN
THEY CARRIED INTO THEIR HOUSE
THIS BILL IS GOING TO AFFECT
THOSE PEOPLE THE POOREST IN OUR
COMMUNITY. IT SAYS THAT IT TAKES
TWENTY GALLONS TO WASH THESE
DISHES BY HAND. PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO DO THEIR DISHES THESE PEOPLE
ARE VERY. VERY FAMILY ORIENTATED
VERY CLEAN INDIVIDUALS THEY CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT THE WAY THEIR HOUSE
FLICKS- EVEN SOME OF THEM THAT
HAVE CRAXI MEANT THAT THEY LIVE
ON- WE VISITED WITH THEM THEY
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THE WAY THEIR
HOUSE LOOKS. AND THEY'RE GOING
TO DO THEIR DISHES BUT THEY
DON'T HAVE A HIGH ENERGY
EFFICIENT DISHWASHER THAT'S ONLY
GONNA USE FOUR GALLONS- THERE'S
A LOT OF THINGS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FRESNO MY COLLEAGUE FROM TO
HEMA PUT FORTH THAT BILL TO
ALREADY USE. WATER RESOURCES
THAT WERE ALREADY ALLOCATED BY
THE VOTERS IN ORDER TO BUILD
WATER STORAGE IT WAS SHOT DOWN
IN THE FIRST COMMITTEE AS IT WAS
STATED EARLIER. I CAN TELL YOU
THERE'S NEW BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS
ON AL FLOWS INTO THE DELTA WERE
MORE WATER CAN BE SENT TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY- IN. THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE NOT HAPPEN
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH WATER ALREADY
WOULD HAVE WATER. I CAN TELL YOU
THAT REPRESENTING. WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM FRESNO THE TOP
THREE FOOD PRODUCING COUNTIES IN
THE WORLD THAT I REALIZE THIS IS
AN IN HOME ISSUE. BUT WE NEED
WATER TO GROW FOOD. TOP THREE
FOOD PRODUCING COUNTIES IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD AND LIKE I SAID I
KNOW THIS BILL DOESN'T AFFECT
THAT. AND I DO BELIEVE THAT WE
ALL NEED CONSERVATION BECAUSE WE
CANNOT CONSERVE OUR WAY OUT OF
THIS SITUATION. SO ITMAKES ME
SICK TO MY STOMACH THAT WATER IS
JUST A VOLATILE POLITICAL ISSUE.
WE SHOULD ALL COME TOGETHER. AND
WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND MAKE SURE
THAT. EVERY SINGLE CALIFORNIAN
HAS A RIGHT TO WATER INCLUDING
THOSE IMPORTER BILL THAT HAVE
NOT HAD WATER IN ALMOST TWO AND
A HALF YEARS. THE GO TO THE
DITCH TO GET WATER TO BRING BACK
TO THEIR HOUSE TO WASH CLOTHES.
IF YOU WERE TO SIT DOWN AND TALK
TO THE FARMWORKERS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THOUSANDS OF THEM
WOULD TELL YOU. THAT THE BIGGEST
STRUGGLE THEY HAVE IS SOME OF
THE POLICIES THAT COME OUT OF
THIS BUILDING THAT CREATE MORE
COST FOR THEM. THIS BILL IS
EXACTLY LIKE THIS NO MATTER HOW
WELL INTO IT IT IS. WE
DEFINITELY WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
RIGHT ASK YOU ALL TO LOOK AT THE
BILL THAT WAS BROUGHT FORTH BY
MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO
ENTERTAINMENT. SO THAT WE COULD
ACTUALLY LOOK AT ALLOCATING
RESOURCES FOR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. I APPLAUD MY
COLLEAGUES FRIENDS AND KINGS
COUNTY. FROM SANGER WHO-
ACTUALLY GOT RESOURCES FOR FIVE
NINE NINE FOR DELIVERY SYSTEM SO
THAT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. CAN'T
CONVEY WATER FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NO VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER THE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE HEARING TINA
SYNERGY BURKE WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT IS A LOT OF ISSUES
THAT ARE RAISED I JUST WANNA.
DEAL WITH A HANDFUL OF THEM AND
I WANT TO THANK. THE SENATORS MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THE DISCUSSION
AND CERTAINLY REFLECTING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE IN ALL CORNERS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I KNOW
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT ARGUED
INVOLVING FIRES AND PROP ONE BUT
IS- CENTER FROM RIVERSIDE SAID
THEY'RE NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT IF WE HAD A
BILL UP. SO TO SPEAK DEALING
WITH MILES PER GALLON TO BE ABLE
TO INCREASE THE MILEAGE OF
AUTOMOBILES. THE FOLKS AND SAY
NO WE CAN'T DO THAT BECAUSE WE
GOT TO GET INTERNAL COMBUSTION
ENGINES OFF THE- OFF THE ROAD.
CERTAINLY IT'S AN IMPORTANT PART
OF THE LARGER CONTEXT BUT IT IS
NOT THE CORE OF THIS BILL. THE
QUESTION I AS AND I WANT TO
JUST THE POVERTY ISSUE IN SOME
OF THESE OTHER ISSUES I THINK
ARE IMPORTANT BUT BASICALLY.
WHAT IF WE DIDN'T CONSERVE
VERSIONS WE GET CONSERVE WATER
FOR RIGHT PERSONS WERE WRONG.
YOU FOR ME FOR WRONG THE WORST
CASE SCENARIO IS. THAT WE HAVE
MORE WATER TO GROW MORE FOOD IN
THE STATE WHERE AGRICULTURE IS
SO IMPORTANT HE FOR WRONG WILL
HAVE MORE WATER FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. THEN THE FISHY SO
MANY OTHER THINGS THAT MEET THE
DISCUSSION OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE. OKAY WONDERFUL
RIGHT WHAT IF THIS WAS SUGGESTED
BY MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES WE DO
RUN OUT OF WATER WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH THAT WE NEED TO GET AHEAD
OF THE GAME IS THE CHAIR OF THE
WATER COMMITTEE SAID TO GET
AHEAD OF THIS PROCESS AND TO BE
SMART ABOUT IT RIGHT SO WHAT IS
THE IMPACT WHAT ARE WE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT HERE IS BECAUSE WE
ARE MEETING THOSE GOALS LET ME
LET ME JUST ADDRESS A COUPLE OF
ISSUES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. THEM
I WON'T TAKE TOO MUCH TIME OKAY
NUMBER ONE COST IMPACT ON PEOPLE
OF LESSER MEANS A TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN STUDY BY THE ALLIANCE
FOR WATER EFFICIENCY FOUND THAT
THE LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF
WATER AND POWER CONSERVE THE
CONSERVATION PROGRAM AVOID THE
BILL ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
WATER COST CONSUMER BILLS
CUSTOMERS BILLS 426% LOWER THAN
THEY OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE BEEN
IN TERMS OF IMPACT ON PEOPLE OF
LESSER MEANS WATER COSTS. SECOND
THE IDEA. OF LOOKING AT THIS
HOLISTICALLY AND SAYING LESS
WATER PER PERSON WHAT IS A
GALLON PER. PER CAPITA PER DAY
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
STANDARDS WHAT YOU'RE REQUIRED
TO LOOK AT HERE. IS IT'S NOT
CHEST. URBAN WATER SUPPLIERS
RETAIN THE EXISTING FLEXIBILITY
UNDER THIS BILL IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE. O MEET THEIR WATER
OBJECTIVES. CALCULATED BY THE
FOLLOWING NOT JUST HOW YOU FLUSH
YOUR TOILET HOW LONG YOU TAKE A
SHOWER YES IT INCLUDES INDOOR
RESIDENTIAL USAGE. INCLUDES
OUTDOOR RESIDENTIAL USES
COMMERCIAL INDUSTRIAL
INSTITUTIONAL OUTDOOR WATER
USAGE SYSTEM WIDE WATER LOSSES.
GIVES CREDIT FOR VARIANCES WERE
ACCOUNTS ARE UNIQUE TO LOCAL
SITUATIONS. AND INCLUDES POTABLE
REUSE BONUSES INCENTIVE
ADJUSTMENTS WHICH IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO ORANGE
COUNTY WHICH IN MY JUDGMENT HAS
BY ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE THE
PLATINUM STANDARD THE BEST
STANDARD FOR. WATER RECYCLING A
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND ACRE
FEET THEY ARE THE BEST IN THE
BUSINESS. AND SO THE CHALLENGES
I WILL TALK TO THE SENATOR FROM
IRVINE ABOUT BECAUSE I'VE SPENT
A LOT OF TIME STUDYING THIS. SO
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BIG PICTURE
IN TERMS OF CONSERVATION CAN WE
DO IT. I WILL GO THROUGH THE
DETAILS BECAUSE WE'RE OUT OF
TIME BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS YES
WE CAN YES WE CAN. THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT. ARE THIS REALLY IS
ABOUT THE NEXT GENERATION THIS
REALLY IS ABOUT YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN THIS REALLY IS
ABOUT GOVERNING NOT FOR THE NEXT
ELECTION. BUT FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION THAT IS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE TO GET AHEAD
OF THE CURVE. FOR SOMETHING
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT IN THE
COMMUTER URBAN COMMITTEES I
REPRESENT LOS ANGELES THERE'S
NOT A NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL THAT
I CAN'T GO TO. THE DOESN'T TALK
ABOUT WATER BECAUSE WE IMPORT
WATER AND WE HAVE TO LOS
ANGELES. ESPECIALLY WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE COLORADO RIVER
STE WE ALREADY OVER DREW OUR OUR
ALLOCATION BY NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRE FEET. TO REDUCE
OUR DEMAND TO REDUCE OUR DEMAND
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT FOR AGRICULTURE SO.
IF WE DO REDUCE OUR DEMAND WE
HAVE A LARGER PICTURE. OF WHAT
WE'RE HERE. IT'S NOT A BAD THING
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING
TECHNOLOGICALLY ISRAEL WHAT DID
THEY DO. GEISHA'S SYSTEM WHAT DO
YOU DO IN AGRICULTURE RFID RADIO
FREQUENCY TAGS ACTUALLY THE TREE
AND TELL YOU HOW MUCH WATER IT
NEEDS. TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN
BRILLIANT ACROSS THE GLOBE TO BE
ABLE TO DEAL WITH WATER IN A
MUCH MORE ELEGANT WAY. THAN HOW
WE'RE DEALING WITH IT IT IS SO
IMPORTANT IS A HUMAN RIGHT IT IS
ALL OF THOSE THINGS THAT A
MOLDED FOLKS TO STAND TODAY. AND
SO THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA OVER
ONE MILLION CUSTOMERS. WHERE
WHERE WHERE WHERE INTERVIEWED A
HUNDRED FIFTY WATER AGENCIES
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING YOU JUST
PULLED OFF THE SHELF BUT IT WAS
THE RESULT OF TWO YEARS OF
STUDY. FROM OUR GOVERNMENT WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE
LIKE I ASK YOUR RIVALS. THANK
YOU HELLO THIS. BETA SECTOR
PLEASED THE ROLL ON FILE ITEMS
SEVEN. TH ALLEN. I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS. AYE BATES. NO BACKER
. I FOR JUST NO BRADFORD.
CABALLERO AYE PROTESTING AYE
DALY NO DOG HI TORONTO I EGGMAN
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
NO HERTZBERG AYE WESSEL AYE
FURTADO NO JONES. NO KAMLAGER I
LAYERED. I LEYVA AYE LIMÓN AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO MEN I
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN NO CHOI BOGUE
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO. SKINNER I STERN AYE
NUMBER AYE AYE CASKEY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BRADFORD. RUBIO WELL.
MARCH TWENTY EIGHTH KNOWS NINE
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BEFORE WE TAKE UP TO
CONSENT CALENDARS OR ANY MEMBER
WISHING TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. HEARING
SEEN NONE WE HAVE EIGHT ITEMS
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION FOURTEEN
SENATE BILLS. ELEVEN SEVENTY
NINE TEN ELEVEN TEN NINETY THREE
ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE TWELVE FORTY
TO FOURTEEN SEVENTY THREE AND
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY. THANK YOU. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES. AYE BAKER
. I PORCHES HI BRADFORD ART I
HAVE ITEM I FOR TAXIS I DALY. I
DODD I THE RUSSELL HI EGGMAN I
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH AYE
HERTZBERG. I WEST SEVENTY. I HER
TADO I JONES I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED. I LEYVA AYE THE MON. HI
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S AYE MIN
AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN AYE A
CHOI BOGUE I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
I STERN I AM BURKE I Y. CASKEY
AYE WIENER AYE WILK. HIGHS
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO ON FILE ITEM
ONE TWO OZ THIRTY NINE THOSE
ZEROS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
PROCESS. NOW MEMBERS REMOVED
TICKET COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
ARE THERE ANY COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR BAKER DO
YOU HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT. YES
THE A JOINT CLIMATE CHANGE
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS AFTER
ADJOURNMENT. IS IT ROOM ONE
ELEVEN- ACTUALLY THE REMOTE
ELEVEN HUNDRED HERE YEAH I LIVE
IN HUNDRED OKAY. US THE A JOINT
CLIMATE CHANGE COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING IN HE SWING SPACE AND
ROOM ELEVEN HUNDRED AFTER
TERMINUS SESSION SOONER ATKINS
THE JUSTICE CLEAR. NOT WE'RE
JUST I'M SORRY CENTER. TO THE
FLOOR. I'M SORRY PREVENTION OF
POLLUTION FLOOR PLEASE GRANT
THANK YOU OUR COLLEAGUES I JUST
WANTED TO WISH YOU ALL A HAPPY
EASTER NOW I KNOW MOST EVERYONE
CELEBRATE THIS LAST WEEK BUT FOR
THOSE THAT ARE OF THE ORTHODOX
FAITH WE FOLLOW THE JULIAN
CALENDAR SO THIS SUNDAY IS GOING
TO BE- EASTER SO WE'RE VERY
EXCITED TO HAVE SOME LAMB ON A
SPIT. SO FOR THOSE THAT ARE NOT
GREEK ORTHODOX FOLLOWERS GREW IT
GREW GREEK RESTAURANT THIS IS
THE BEST TIME OF YEAR TO GO. GOT
IT. IF THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
CENTER I CAN SUGGEST IS COLOR.
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH COLLEAGUES THANK YOU HAVE
YOU HAD A GOOD LAST WEEKEND A
GOOD THIS WEEKEND- WHATEVER YOU
CELEBRATE- BUT BE SAFE AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING YOU ALL
ON MONDAY APRIL TWENTY FIFTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT TWO PM.
THANK YOU. THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME AN ADJOURNMENT MOTION
WILL BE MADE WILL RECONVENE ON
MONDAY AT TWO PM THANK YOU.